[Musique]
Henry gu bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement succintement ça c'est le
plus difficile je suis né en 57 à arle
euh dans
un d'une mère qui était femme de ménage
j'ai été élevé par ma mère et ma
grand-mère voilà puis j'ai fait des des
études de de sciences politique
d'économie d'histoire
ah
j'ai partagé ma carrière entre le
secteur public et l'administration et le
secteur privé la banque
l'assurance
je je suis devenu Gauliste à l'âge de 8
ans regardant une photo du enfin une
petite gravure représentant général de
Gaul dans un livre d'histoire écrit en
dessous la France avait la France a
perdu une bataille mais elle n'a pas
perdu la
guerre
golisme naïf en Fontain mais qui petit à
petit est devenu un peu plus euh un peu
plus élaboré et et je suis
passionné pour la
politique finalement assz assez tôt je
n'ai milité qu'assz tard voilà
euh à part ça le le les hasards de les
hasards de l'Histoire m'ont amené à
rencontrer des
gens qui
m'ont qui m'ont donné envie de
de participer au débat public de prendre
des
responsabilités donc j'ai été
euh j'ai été un adversaire résolu du
traité de Maastrich ce qui m'a donné
l'occasion de faire ma première campagne
de ma première campagne politique
j'avais pris 3 mois de congé sabatique
pour pour faire cette campagne la plus
la première et la plus belle de ma vie
parce que c'est une campagne où on
demandait rien à personne on demandait
pas aux gens de voter pour euh pour soi
euh on a perdu de de très peu donc j'ai
fait cette campagne avec avec Philippe
ségin et et Charles pascoy euh alors
après ensuite
j'ai j'ai quitté un temps le secteur
privé pour pour faire du
cabinet ministériel
j'ai été l'un des inspirateurs de la
campagne de Chirac sur la fracture
sociale en en 95
euh puis j'ai contribué à celle à celle
de Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007
euh voilà
avec un rôle
qui peut-être pas décisif mais en tout
cas
important à chaque à chaque fois puis
j'ai étéis j'étais entretemps
commissaire général au
Plan et euh et puis
après la victoire de Sarkozy en
2007 son conseiller spécial à l'Élysée
pendant pendant 5 ans voilà puis ensuite
j'ai
regagné un grand corps de
l'administration dans lequel j'avais été
intégré bien des années auparavant
voilà c'est la deuxième fois qu'on vous
reçoit on avait déjà parlé de des
menaces qui se profilé pour la France
aujourd'hui on va parler de la guerre on
va parler de la géopolitique on va
parler des perspectives que qui s'ouvre
de devant la France des des peut-être
des sommets à
gravir la première question on a regardé
beaucoup de vos interviews fraîches
euh j'ai remarqué peut-être que je me
trompe que vous étiez très triste quand
vous évoquiez le sujet de la guerre
pourquoi la deuxième question c'est
est-ce que vos parents vous ont compté
des histoires de
guerre d'abord répondre à la à la
deuxième question
ma grand-mère en avait vu en avait vécu
deux mon grand-père avait été gazé
pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale je je me souviens d'aller
encore tout jeune avec ma grand-mère à
l'association des blessés du poumon
ou des vétérans de la guerre de la
Première Guerre
mondiale continuer de rendre des
services à la à ceux qui avaient été qui
avaient é gazé euh je n'ai pas connu mon
grand-père mais
euh mais ma grand-mère m'en
a m'a beaucoup parlé de ces de ces deux
guerres qui ont été à la fois des des
moments d'angoisse et et et des moments
de privation surtout pour pour des
milieux modestes
euh elle avait toujours cette cette
cette formule tu tu verras quand ce sera
la guerre
c'est c'est pour dire la vie est facile
aujourd'hui mais voilà n'oublie pas
queelle peut être très très très dur
voilà euh voilà mes souvenirs de mes
souvenirs de guerre je nai vécu de loin
que dans mon enfance que la la guerre
d'Algérie mais mais euh mais de très
très loin ça ne paraissait encore ça ne
paraissait quelque chose
de
très très étrange voilà pas ça ne
rentrait pas c'était pas une gar qui
rentrait dans la vie quotidienne sauf
dans les familles
ou
où où
les les enfants étaient mobilisés est ce
qui n'était pas le cas de la
mienne
la la première
question j'y répondrai peut-être de la
de la façon
suivante
comment comment ne pas être à la fois
triste et
angoissé par l'état actuel du monde et
par cette espèce
d'aveuglement qui
finalement conduit depuis toujours
à à l'engrenage des guerres et de et de
la violence
c'est je suis je suis frappé par le le
le fait que nous avons enfin notre
société a oublié ce qui était la guerre
elle en parle parfois avec une
désinvolture ou une
légèreté étonnante
et et elle a oublié aussi ce qui était
l'engrenage de
la l'engrenage de la violence qui
conduit à l'engrenage de la guerre et à
à la montée aux extrêmes et au fond
c'est peut-être la question la plus
importante
qui se pose aujourd'hui à nous
tous moi
je je suis frappé par le fait que le le
le débat public a atteint un degré de
superficialité qui est en rité
extrêmement préoccupant et même
extrêmement dangereux c'est c'est nous
avons oublié qu'au au commencement de
tout il y a la violence de la nature et
la violence de l'homme
euh vience de nature on la connaît he
c'est c'est la loi du plus fort la
sélection
naturelle et la violence de l'homme elle
est dans la nature de l'homme parce que
l'homme fait partie de la nature et et
et
tout tout l'effort de l'humanité de
l'humanisation
euh est un un un un effort pour
endiguer cette cette violence qui est
dans chacun d'entre nous alors je sais
bien
chacun pense qu'il ne peut pas devenir
enfin beaucoup pensent qu'il ne peuvent
pas peut pas devenir qu' peuvent pas
devenir violents
euh qui sont très différents de des
générations qui nous ont
précédé et en réalité nous sommes tous
capables du meilleur sans doute mais
aussi du pire parce que cette violence
est en chacun d'entre nous et
que la civilisation la
culture les institutions le droit
l'éducation tout cela au fond est
d'abord fait pour endiguer cette
violence autant que
possible tant bien que
mal sans toujours sans toujours
évidemment y parvenir et ce qui est
certain c'est que lorsque toutes ces
digues que nous dressons contre notre
propre violence s'
frite au point libérer cette violence
cette violence elle sort de nous et elle
dévore tout sur son passage
et un événement récent qui j'ai j'ai
trouvé très
frappant qui illustre cette espèce de
cet oubli de notre propre
nature ce qui s'est passé
eu la la veille de des attentats
de en Israël
ou des jeunes gens des jeune juif
faisait la fête à quelques kilomètres de
de
Gaza ils
avaient oublié toute cette cette
violence qui est dans l'homme ils
avaient même oublié 2000 ans de
persécution ça ne pouvait plus arriver
dans leur esprit ça ne pouvait plus
arriver et au petit matin les les
assassins sont
arrivés
et d'un coup ça a réveillé dans les
consciences juives du monde et même dans
dans les
consciences beaucoup de conscience
humaine ça a réveillé le souvenir de de
de toutes ces violences de toutes ces
sauvageries dont l'histoire de l'homme
est est parsemée savez on parle
par on parle de
de des exactions de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale de doradour surglan par exemple
comme si c'était un événement
extraordinaire dans dans l'histoire des
de l'humanité en réalité desoradour
surglan il y en a il y en a eu des
dizaines des centaines des milliers
depuis le le début de l'humanité c'est
euh et nous Français au Moyen-Âge
pendant les guerres de religion nous en
avons commis nous en avons commis
beaucoup qui se déroule à peu près de la
même façon on ferme les gens dans
l'église et on brûle tout voilà c'est ça
veut pas dire que l'histoire serait
rpète parce que les circonstances
changent
mais nous nous nous répétons nous nous
répétons sans
arrêt parce que nous ne changeons pas de
nature et ce que nous apprend l'histoire
au fond
c'est sont pas des recettes pour pour
l'avenir mais ce que nous apprend
l'histoire fondamentale c'est c'est ce
que nous sommes elle nous montre ce que
nous sommes ce dont nous sommes capables
encore une fois pour le meilleur mais
aussi pour le pour le pire et et si on
ne pense pas à tout cela
euh on passe à côté de l'essentiel face
au aux événements auquel nous sommes
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui confrontés euh
oui au de commencement de tout il y a il
y a la il y a la violence
euh d'ailleurs cette violence elle est
elle est fondatrice c'est c'est toutes
les alliances éternelles tous les euh
tout toutes les haines
inextinguibles mais aussi toutes nos
institutions toutes nos sociétés sont
sont fondé sur la violence elles ont
elles ont elles trouvent leur fondement
dans dans le
sacrifice le sacré qui est une chose
tellement importante dans dans les
sociétés humaines le
sacré il est fondé sur le sacrifice
toujours il y il n'y a pas de société
humaine il y a pas de nation il y a pas
de peuple qui ne soit fondé sur le
sacrifice et donc sur la sur la violence
alors
là la violence qui qui qui accouche même
de la culture le le passage de la nature
à la culture c'est le c'est le passage
de la violence euh débridé à la violence
ritualisée espèce de
catarciste qui qui va permettre de pas
l'homme de s'organiser en société de de
d'extérioriser de de réguler cette de
réguler cette cette violence et la
guerre bien la guerre
c'est c'est la la porte ouverte sur
cette violence totalement libérée qui
dévore tout sur son passage qu'est-ce
que la guerre la guerre c'est
lorsque deux personnes face à face se
disent l'une et l'autre c'est lui ou moi
lorsque deux peuples face à face se
disent l'un et l'autre c'est lui ou moi
la guerre c'est c'est quand le
meurtre devient une
vertu c'est quand le le crime est
encensé et il est fatal puisque
ù c'est moi qui tue l'ennemi ou c'est
l'ennemi qui me
tue la guerre c'est c'est l'échec du
droit c'est l'échec de la
civilisation c'est l'échec de la
culture c'est l'échec de la
politique c'est pas la politique par
d'autres moyens non je ne crois pas je
crois que c'est pas la politique par
notre moyen c'est l'échec de la
politique
c'est pour régler les les conflits
innombrables qui opposent les hommes nou
les peuples les uns aux autres c'est sûr
il y a d'abord le droit mais le droit ça
ne fonctionne que si tout le monde est
décidé à adhérer à la règle de droit
c'està-dire
si si tout le monde en reconnaît la
légitimité la question du droit pose
toujours la première la question de la
légitimité c'est si tout le monde trouve
ce droit légitime et prêt à partager
cette légitimité ces
règles bien on règle le problème devant
devant un tribunal ou ou par un
arbitrage bon
euh mais quand c'est pas le
cas le droit ne ne sert plus à rien on
reviendra peut-être pe plus tard sur le
droit international mais mais euh le
vivons aussi dans l'illusion que que que
le notre nature humaine aurait changé au
au point que le droit serait devenu
quelque chose de plus fort que la que la
nature humaine euh ça ça c'est une très
dangereuse illusion et quand le droit ne
h nopère plus et bien on passe à autre
chose cette autre chose c'est quand il
s'agit des rapports entre les entre les
peuples entre les
nations c'est autre chose c'est la
diplomatie et la politique c'est-à-dire
que voilà on a on a plus de il y a plus
de recettees il faut bricoler il faut il
faut il faut négocier il faut marchander
il faut pour
éviter pour pour éviter le massacre et
puis quand on n arrive pas quand ça ne
fonctionne pas et bien il reste la
guerre ce qui frappant le dans dans ce
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui c'est quand
même
que on a le sentiment que la diplomatie
et la et la et la et la politiqu n n'ont
pas droit de citer dire c'est
il tout se passe comme si c'est il est
immoral de négocier immoral de de
discuter de marchander
de immoral de faire de la politique pour
éviter de de passer notre temps à nous
entretuer voilà c'est
c'est ça c'est c'est une encore une fois
c'est une impasse terrible sur la sur la
nature
humaine encore une fois je crois qu'il
faut regarder histoire pour comprendre
enfin l'istoire au moins des guerres
dont nous nous souvenons
encore nous nous souvenons pas de tout
de toutes les
guerres qui se souvient encore dans même
dans sinon dans un inconscient collectif
très lointain de la guerre de 30 ans qui
a été une guerre civile européenne une
guerre de
religion bien pire encore que la la la
Première Guerre mondiale
elle a tué dans en Europe centr dans
entre un tiers et la moitié de la
population elle a duré 30 ans c'est une
succession de de de massacre
invraisemblable voilà elle se situe au
moment où la certain nombre de d'États
européens passent à la réforme
et çaen rappelle plus
mais même si les fantômes sont toujours
sont sont sont toujours là mais mais
essayons de revenir les les les
engrenages qui nous ont conduit
directement à la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui que ce soit
d'ailleurs au Moyen-Orient ou en Ukraine
euh je crois qu'il faut
repartir pour repartir de la Première
Guerre mondiale dont on parlait au début
de au début de de l'entretien
euh la guerre de 14 celle qu'on appel la
guerre de 14 ou la ou la Grande Guerre
euh
elle est elle est le fruit d'un d'un
d'un
engrenage que dont personne ne
souhaitait ne souhaitait euh qu'il qu'il
débouchass sur une sur sur une telle
tuerie en on a commencé par l'appeler la
drôle de guerre c'est ça non ça c'était
en 1939 39 d'accord euh non
c'est à partir de la bon l'Empire
allemand se se se constitue euh dans les
années 1860
et puis en 1870
euh la quand la Prusse rassemble s sous
son aile tous les états dispersés de
enfin de de
l'Allemagne dur jusqu'à la Prusse
premièrement en en en faisant la guerre
d'abord à l'Autriche enfin l'Autriche
Hongrie qui
est l'Empire qui tient la moitié de la
moitié de de Europe et puis et puis
ensuite à la France c'est la guerre de
1870 que la France va va perdre qui va
la conduire à à
abandonner à céder à l'Allemagne
l'Alsace et la
Moselle euh alors c'était aussi une
espèce de revanche sur les guerres
napoléoniennes
euh voilà habilement tout ça cette
politique habilement conduite par par
Bismark et qui va fonder l'Empire
allemand jusque là il y avait eu le
Saint-Empire romain germanique puis
l'Empire
aostrongrois né à ce moment-là l'Empire
allemand qui regroupe à part l'Autriche
à peu près tous les des pays allemands
de la de de tous les pays allemands de
l'Europe passer sur la façon dont dont
dont dont on a réglé l'issue de cette de
cette cette guerre le mais euh on
apprenait ça jadis dans dans les livres
d'histoire c'est c'est 1870 et la fin du
enfin la fin du Second Empire la France
est batue
euh perd presque pratiquement toutes ces
batailles elle perd en particulier à San
où l'empereur Napoléon II qui s'est
placé à la tête de l'armée est fait
capturé enfin capitule et il est capturé
par il est fait prisonnier par les par
les Allemands par les Prussiens euh il
refuse d'ailleurs il refuse de signer la
capitulation de la France capitule avec
ses troupes mais il refuse un
gouvernement provisoire se crée à Paris
euh animé
par par des des des républicains euh qui
fondent de la la qui vont fonder alors
ça ce sera un peu plus tard qu'il vont
fonder la 3e république mais euh pendant
un gouvernement provisoire on se
souvient vienent tous là de l'image de
de de de de Gambetta qui tend Paris en
ballon Paris assiégé par les par les
Allemands pour essayer de former une
armée sur la Loire qui va pourra essayer
de briser le le cercle
de les trintes les trintes des armées
allemandes et
puis souviens aussi de la la Commune de
Paris c'est cette révolte sociale et
politique éclate à qui qui éclate à
Paris le gouvernement s'en va se
réfugier à
Versailles ce qu'on a appelé le parti
des Versaillais qui qui va en réalité
négocier avec les les Allemands parce
que
euh ce ce gouvernement qui représente
une partie de la bourgeoisie auquel se
sont ralliés les les royalistes
euh pense
que négocier avec les Allemands c'est
c'est moins dramatique que de prendre le
risque de la révolution de la Révolution
communarde euh c'est en en gros mieux
vaut les Allemands que que que les
communistes les anarchistes à l'époque
c'est ça
oui enfin c'est monarchist si on veut
enfin la la Commune de Paris c'est c'est
c'est ça n'est pas vraiment c'est c'est
pas l'anarchie c'est vraiment une
une c'est c'est vraim c'est une révolte
social très très dur et on trouve de
tout chez les cominardin mais mais euh
pour Marx c'est c'est la c'est le début
de la révolte du du du prolétariat c'est
euh donc c'est une révolte très violente
hein c'est mais tout sera très violent à
ce moment-là la les communares vont tuer
beaucoup de gens
euh ils vont
détruire un certain nombre de monumentss
Parisiens fusiller des prêtres bon euh
et puis les
Versaillais une fois libéré de la
pression allemande qui les laisse qui
les laisse mener la répression dans dans
dans Paris vont massacrer aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de gens donc c'est un bain de
sang euh considérable c'est c'est
d'ailleurs sur c'est sur ce bain de sang
que va se fonder la nouvelle la la
Nouvelle République
euh à partir de là évidemment le le le
se crée dans le euh dans l'esprit
français la la
sentiment defin la volonté d'une
revanche on a perdu la la Jaz et
damoiselle pendant des décennies on
verra sur les livres d'histoire dans
dans toutes les écoles de France sur
toutes les
cartes qui sont sont affiché ce ce ce
morceau de de ce morceau de France qui
nous a été
arraché et la France va préparer sa
revanche
les Allemands vont vivre eux dans le
dans le avec le sentiment que la France
cherchera cherche sa revanche à tout
prix se rajoute à ça d'autres
considérations propre à d'autres
pays l'Autriche Hongrie d'abord qui veut
qui veut pousser son avantage dans les
Balcans la Russie qui est alliée à la à
la Serbie qui rêve de réunir les Balcans
sous son autorité euh quand les
Autrichiens rêvent de la réunir sous de
de réunir les Balcans sous la leur euh
donc il y a des jeux d'alliances qui
vont se qui vont qui vont se se se
former
euh la France
va va consolider l'alliance anglaise
euh avec l'Entente cordiale malgré les
les rivalité coloniale et puis la
l'alliance va une alliance va se forgé
entre la France et et la Russie alors
c'est un calcul très rationnel pour pour
pour les Français c'est-à-dire euh avoir
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne une alliance de
revers mais pour les Allemands euh c'est
le c'est le sentiment d'être d'être
encerclé donc euh des Allemands eux vont
vivre
et avec avec cette idée
que
ils peuvent être attaqués sur deux
fronts et qu'il faut il faut prévoir au
cas où la guerre
éclaterait de de
pouvoir attaquer sur un front détruire
le le le le premier avant de se
retourner vers le second enfin il a
cette cette angoisse d'être pris en
tenaille entre les deux euh vous
rajoutez à ça des rivalités colonial
entre
la entre
l'Allemagne et l'Angleterre et la et la
France parce que l'Allemagne qui n'a pas
d'empire colonial veut créer un empire
auss un empire colonial bon et
euh il y aura une succession de de de
crise qui chaque
fois chaque fois sont bord de déboucher
sur un conflit qui va être chaque fois
évité arriver CIN fois moins dans dans
les dans les cinq crises internationales
qui vont être très très dangereuses
mais tout le monde s'était forcé
d'éviter le le pire à chaque fois puis
arrive un cet accident euh enfin
accident ce
se cet attentat euh en juin 1914 à
sarevo où l'archiduc héritier de
d'Autriche euh est en voyage officiel à
Sarajevo saragevo est une province des
Balcans qui appartient enfin qui est
occupée par la par les Autrichiens qui a
été annexé par les Autrichiens et la
l'archiduc est assassiné on soupçonne
les services secret Serb d'avoir
commandité le
l'assassinat mais bon ça ça n'est au
fond qu'un attentat parmi d'autres
personne à cet instant ne pense que de
cet attentat va naître la Première
Guerre mondiale et que qui va faire 20
millions de morts personnes et pendant
pendant des
semaines tout le monde au fond ses
forces de de de ne pas en arrivé au au
pire alors il y a bien les autrichiens
qui veulent donner des leçons aux Serbes
et qui sont alliés aux Allemands
euh
mais le la Russie qui menace si on
attaque les Serbes de de rentrer en
guerre
mais tous les les témoignages qu'on a
euh montre en fait qu' il y a une
personne ne croit à la guerre personne
personne est jusqu'au dernier moment
d'ailleurs les
euh
beaucoup de de de de gens vont
s'efforcer de l'éviter en particulier
d'ailleurs les l'empereur d'Allemagne
Guillaume I et le et Nicolas i le Dar de
de de Russie qui jusqu'au dernier moment
ont s'est changé des lettres pour pour
essayer de trouver un un moyen d'éviter
ce ce ce ce conflit qui est
euh qui est le F le le fruit de toutes
les alliances qui ont qui ont été qui
enfin qui va être le fruit de toutes les
alliances qui ont été qui ont été
conclues euh entre les différents pays
d'Europe pour se protéger des pour se
protéger des autres
euh et puis finalement ça ça arrive et
ça arrive à un moment où les
euh les
Russes décident d'une mobilisation
partiel de leur de leur troupes euh et
puis dans la foulée une mobilisation
générale quand les Allemands voient
que les Russes décrèent une mobilisation
générale bah ils pensent qu'ils vont
être attaqués que ils vont pris en
tenaille à ce momentl il déclare la
guerre donc c'est c'est l'Allemagne qui
a déclaré la guerre c'est elle qui est
responsable de la guerre
enfin en se mettant un instant à la
place de de à la à la place des des des
Allemands on voit bien que c'est c'est
un engrenage qui partir du moment o quel
l'un des des protagonistes mettait le le
le le le doigt dans dans ce processus la
guerre serait serait générale c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire que d'un
seul coup tout s'est embrasé du du jour
au lendemain une Europe qui vivait dans
l'insouciance et
qui qui tout en tout en sachant que les
tensions existaient que
que les les arsenaux étai étaient plein
que les plans étaient é rédigé pour
attaquer le voisin
euh C cette Europe d'un seul coup c'est
s'est trouvé confronté à
à trou confronté à la guerre c'est c'est
euh alors que les la bonne société la
bonne
société européenne était sur les plages
pendant pendant
l'été puis d'un seul coup voilà la
guerre éclate et elle elle se répand
elle se répand très très vite à à toute
l'Europe dans les empires centux
c'està-dire la
l'Allemagne l'autrichehongrie et la et
l'Empire ottoman
contre la Russie la France et
l'Angleterre et ça ça ça n'est pas s'en
rappeler un peu ce qui s'est passé en en
Ukraine les
Allemands pensant que que il fallait
donc fallait obtenir une défaite une
victoire décisive sur un des deux frs
pouvoir se retourner contre contre
l'autre
avait avait mis au point les plan d'une
guerre éclaire contre la France donc ils
ont entamé leur guerre éclaire app ça le
plan schliffen qui a été qui avait été
remagé plusieurs fois consistait à
à à pénétrer en France par un grand
mouvement tournant qui l'inverse de
celui qui se produira en 39 en
40 allit très vite
très vite décider de la guerre
d'ailleurs tout le monde pense que cette
guerre ne va pas durer non seulement
pensz qu'elle n'aurait pas lieu mais
quand elle tout le monde pense qu'elle
va pas durer le le le le Kaiser
l'empereur d'Allemagne dit au au soldats
mobilisés vous serez rentrés pour les
moissons ah c'est mais c'était pas un
mensonge tout le monde croyait qu'elle
allait elle n'allait pas durer et puis
la guerre éclaire
échoue comme comme souvent d'ailleurs
c'est parce que la logistique su pas
parce que il
euh des grain de sablees dans la machine
et
puis la réaction la réaction française
elle est
elle est elle est forte et assez
efficace on se souvient enfin la
bataille de la Marne voilà et elle va se
transformer en guerre de
depposition qui va devenir la la guerre
qui va marquer cette cette cette
première guerre mondiale on va faire les
gens vont se figer sur leur sur les
adversaires vont se figer sur leur
position il s'agit plus de il s'agit
plus d'une guerre de mouvement il s'agit
s'agit d'une guerre de tranchée où de
temps en temps on avance de quelques
kilomè au prix de perte énorme et puis
ensuite l'adversaire avance à son tour
au prix de perte énorme voilà qui va
être une des guerres les plus les plus
terribles avec une là encore enfin une
montée aux extrêmes de la violence
que qui est le le le propre de la guerre
et surtout de la encore plus de la
guerre moderne parce que parce que elle
engage toutes les ressources de toutes
les ressources de la nation et on
mobilise des millions d'hommes de part
et d'autre
euh et on compte plus d'ailleurs le on
compte plus la la la vie humaine c'est
c'est
euh le sommet ayant été atteint en
France par le
euh la bataille du Chemin des Dames
l'offensive du Chemin des Dames où le le
chef d'état-major des armées de l'époque
le général nivel euh
euh avait promis à au aux responsables
politiques qu'en 48 he la bataille
serait gagnée la guerre serait gagnée
euh en 48h la bataille était perdue et
il avait dit si on n' pas gagné en 48h
on s'arrête on s'est pas arrêté euh et
cétait ça a été une nécatombe terrible
qui a d'ailleurs fini par par déboucher
sur les les mutineries dans dans l'armée
française et mutineries nonont pas
organisé par des mouvements politiques
pacifistes ou anarchistes ou mais qui
seront peut-être manipulés à certains
instrumentalisés à certains endroits
mais qui sont qui ont qui ont été le
fait de gens qui s'étaient batttu
pendant euh pendant 3 ans qui qui
avaient subi toutes les
souffrances qui avait fait avec un
courage absolument extraordinaire qui
presquement n'en peuvent plus et et
à ce moment-là on a on a failli non pas
gagner la guerre mais mais mais la
perdre c'est à ce nivel a été remplacé
par par Pétin on a on a fusillé quelques
quelques quelques
mutans voilà on a arrêté les grandes
offensives il une une formule très
évocatrice qu'un général avait avait
inventé qui avait fait le tour de
l'armée française
euh face à ces offensives qui faisait
tuer des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de gens pour quelques mètres de
terrain et et euh et cette formule était
c'était attaquons attaquons comme la
lune ça fait sourire mais c'est c'est
euh c'est c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'estàd on a on a fait des des choses
qu'on aurait jamais pensé faire on a
sacrifié un nombre de gens
invraisemblabl euh c'était une nécatombe
et cet écatom personne n'était capable
de
l'arrêter c'est c'est elle il a fallu il
a il a
fallu que l'un des deux soit soit écrasé
pour pour qu'elle pour qu'elle pour
qu'elle s'arrête voilà pour que les
Américains sont arrivés mais ils ont
sont batttu vraiment qu' à l'extrême fin
de la à l'extrême fin de la guerre
elle a épuisé l'Europe
elle a
si on regarde de l'autre côté de de
l'Allemagne
elle a détruit le régime zariste
elle a ouvert la voix à la révolution
russe alors première révolution
bourgeoise et puis ensuite révolution
bolchevvique
euh après euh
elle a
conduit ça c'était une des raisons
fondamentale la Révolution la révolution
russe c'est pas une révolution politique
c'est c'est une révolution euh c'est la
révolution d'unun d'un peuple qui ne
veut qui veut arrêter la guerre parce
que les les pertes sont effroyables
défaites sur défait et pertes
effroyables euh et d'illeurs le premier
gouvernement après la chute du régime
zariste gouverement de Kerenski qui est
un gouvernement de de bourgeois
modéré démocrate et qui veut pas arrêter
la guerre il veut continuer à continuer
la guerre au côté des alliés auokel
près desquels la Russie s'était engagé
euh et la révolution bolchevique elle
elle réussit à cause de ça c'est parce
que ah il y a beaucoup de gens ne
veulent plus de ne veulent plus de la
guerre et et c'est là-dessus que se V
que vont que la
révolution léniniste va battir son son
succès faut voir que le signe la pai de
soviétiques vont signer la paix de
broslitovsk euh la paix de broslitovsk
déjà euh démentelle démentelle l'Empire
russe c'est pendant ce bref moment de
l'histoire que
l'Ukraine émerge comme un État
indépendant la Biélorussie devient un
État indépendant on connaît la suite de
l'histoire la suite de l'histoire c'est
la guerre civile en en en en
Russie sanglante et puis petit à petit
la récupération au bout de quelques
années par les par les Russes par la
Russie de Ukraine de la Biélorussie
enfin tout ce qu'elle avait perdu au
moment de la paix de de brasitovsk
euh faut il faut bien comprendre que
c'est c'est c'est pas le ça ça n'est pas
le commencement du de l'histoire
l'histoire commence pas cette histoire
ne commence pas avec avec la révolution
russe commomence bien avant
euh et à la fin de cette quand quand
quand l'Allemagne s'effondre euh
va se
jouer la suite de la suite de l'histoire
c'est-à-dire que vont se tendre les
ressorts de la tragédie de la de la
tragédie
suivante pourquoi parce que
euh il faut bien faut bien comprendre
que dans dans toute l'histoire de
l'humanité l'humanité depuis que qu'il y
a des civilisations des civilisations
humaines il y a une rivalité éternelle
entre les empires et les nations ou
avant les nations les cités états mais
c'est c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire
des des entités politiques qui reposent
sur un peuple et des entités politiques
qui reposent sur une mosaïque de peuple
un empire c'est une mosaïque de peuple
une nation c'est un peuple voilà une
cité état c'est un peuple Athène c'était
un peuple euh voilà donc cette rivalité
elle est elle est inévitable au fond
elle est aussi inévitable que la
rivalité ou l'éternelle guerre entre les
nomades et les les sédentire
euh et nous réglons toujours très mal la
fin des empires
voilà et ça c'est l'exemple de la
Première Guerre mondiale il est il est
frappant nous en payons encore le prix
aujourd'hui
la les
vainqueurs décident d'un de
de de punir les les empires donc il font
disparaître l'Empire austro-hongrois euh
et ils vont affaiblir considérablement
l'Empire l'Empire allemand donc
euh et pendant ce temps le
le la crise de de de de de l'Empire
russe devenu l'Union soviétique se
déroule de l'autre côté de de l'autre
côté de
l'Europe les les les traités qui vonttre
qui sont qui vont être signés pour M fin
la guerre mondiale
vont vont démanteler les empire au nom
de ce que Wilson appelé président des
États-Unis la la ligne claire des
nationalités voilà
c'est et on va tracer c'est des
frontières don on prend une carte on
trace des frontières en fonction de de
de cette soi-disant ligne clairire des
nationalités en oubliant que dans dans
dans ces dans ces empires les les les
peuples n'étaient pas
seulementent pas les uns à côté des
autres mais dans beaucoup d'endroits
étaient juxaposés les uns aux autres
intriqué intriqué
oui intriqué juxaposé enfin voilà il y a
des régions où bah il y avait des
minorités euh
une minorité polonaise une une
majorité une majorité slovaque il y
avait enfin ou des Roumains et des des
des des Hongrois
bon et donc on va refaire toute la carte
toute la carte de
l'Europe d'abord punir
l'Allemagne arpant l'Allemagne ça veut
dire on démilitarise laarénanie euh on
on on ampute une bonne partie de la
Prusse euh on va reconstituer la la
Pologne qui avait disparu depuis le 18e
siècle qui c'était partagé entre la
Russie
le la Russie la la la Prusse
l'Autriche et on on va
euh on va pendant 15 ans euh
occuper la la Sare qui est la rion la
plus industrielle l'Allemagne euh on va
obliger l'Allemagne à avoir une armée
avec un sans sans armes lourdes avec un
un format très un format très réduit
euh pas d'aviation bon euh pas
d'aviation de guerre en tout
cas
et elle perd des l'emande perd des
millions de de d'Allemands dans dans
cette dans dans dans cette histoire puis
on lui impose des réparations de
guerre il y a bien quelques personnes
qui disent c'est pas très
raisonnable voà c'est c'est Ken dira par
exemple à propos des à propos des à
propos de l'économie il écrira les les
conséquences économiques de la paix qui
donne déjà une idée de ce qui va de ce
qui peut se se
passer tant qu'on écrase on écrase
l'Allemagne et on commence à
éparpiller une partie de la de
l'Allemagne on va aller on va créer des
situations
absurde comme comme celle de
Danzig en recréant la
Pologne on se rend compte que la polne
n'a pas de débouché sur la mer
donc les Alliés décident
de de faire de Danzig ville allemande
populée à 80 plus de 90 %
d'Allemands qui a toujours été allemande
décide d'en faire le port de la Pologne
le grand port de la Pologne alors com
peut pas quand même le donner totalement
au Polonais parce qu'il y a pratiquement
que des Allemands à denti on la met sous
le mandat sous la le gouvernement de
l'asdn et la Société des nations qui est
l'ancêtre de l'ONU qu'on crée à ce à ce
moment-là et puis pour pour la relier
quand même pour que les allemande de
Danzig soit relié à l'Allemagne on crée
un couloir qui s'appelle le couloir de
Danzig
euh qui qui sera évidemment un prétexte
ensuite à des à des tensions très très
très très fortes
euh
on
crée à part la la recréation de la
Pologne on crée deux nouveaux États la
Tchécoslovaquie et la
Yougoslavie on réduit l'Autriche qui
était la tête d'un grand empire un petit
pays de quelques millions d'habitants 8
millions d'habitants je crois qui est le
seul en fait le seul le seul pays
allemand qui n'est pas qui qui qui n'est
pas en Allemagne qui
n'est
euh on va faire la même chose avec
l'Empire ottoman où euh les fondements
de l'Empire ottoman et puis ensuite la
la volonté de de d'atat turque de de
transformer de transformer l'Empire
ottoman en nation turque donc laissant
tomber tout toutes les provinces qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
turques et en continuant une politique
on pourra appeler ça dépuration de de ce
qui n'était pas proprement tur qui avait
commencé qui avait commencé avant mais
mais qui est accéléré donc il se
débarrasse de tous les Grecs de de
d'Asie
mineur ils étaient là quand même de
de depuis euh presque 3000 ans enfin
2500 ans c'est donc il y en a il y a
plus d'un million de Grecs et après une
guerre civile ça sont sont
sont sont réexpédiés en Grèce
euh bon l'éloration des Arméniens avait
commencé bien
avant va rester la question kurde qui
est toujours là mais l'idée d'atat turc
c'est de passer de l'Empire à la nation
voilà de faire une nation turque
euh et tout le reste tout ce que toutes
les pays qu'occupaient la qu'occupait
encore l'Empire ottoman la Grèce et
Balcans sétant libérés de pour une bonne
partie en tout cas depuis de depuis plus
décennies
euh dans tout le reste il faut retracer
des frontières il faut donc les Anglais
et les Français s'attellent à cette
tâche et ils vont dessiner la carte du
Moyen-Orient mais pas en fonction des
réalités géographiques anthropologiques
culturel non ils vont le faire en
fonction de leurs
intérêts ça nous a donné le Moyen-Orient
euh qui est encore celui de
d'aujourd'hui voilà c'est
c'est
donc on a très très mal géré les les les
les fin c'estes fin d'Empire et elles
ont ell les braises ont couvé sous le
sous l'apparence du du droit
international en 19
1925 les pays européens vont se se
réunir
pour
déjà décréter vous déclarer
enfin que les frontières en europeopee
sont intangibles parce tout ce qu'on a
fait il y a évidemment des des il y a
des risques les frontières elles ont
besoin pour s'installer dans dans dans
les têtes dans les dans la géographie s
ont besoin d'énormément de d'énormément
de temps c'est
c'est un fleuve c'est une montagne voilà
et
voyez enfin c'est
c'est c'est là qu'on retrouve retrouve
alors au-delà de la la violence la
nature humaine et il y a il y a autre
chose il y a tout ce qu'on ne voit pas
mais qui qui
détermine qui détermine les les les
comportements des des des humains et des
des personnes des peuples c'est tout ce
qu'on ne voit pas don qu'on même parfois
du mal à à nommer qui nous fait qui nous
font agir t ces choses qui nous font
agir même quand nous n'y pensons pas
même quand nous nous en souvenons pas
euh bordel disait que disait en 1914 les
Allemands et les et les Français
luttaient encore pour le contrôle de la
de la le taringi taringi c'était le le
le résultat du traité de Verdin
Petitfils de charleman se partage se
partage l'Empire donc c'est là que naît
la Francie d'un côté la Germanie enfin
le le le ce qui va être l'Allemagne de
l'autre et puis au milieu il y a il a un
long couloir qui
qui va garder le titre impérial qui
prend l'Italie et tout tout tout ce
qu'il y a entre
la la la la France de l'époque et la et
et l'Allemagne toute cette zone
intermédiaire qui sera l'objet de de
d'incessantes lutte pendant des siècles
et des siècles et B dit bah en 14 il la
France et l'Allemagne étaient encore en
train de se partager mais personne ne
pensait à la lotaringie pour autant mais
quand on regarde une carte on est bien
obligé de se dire que euh le le le
traité de Verdin a marqué pour pour des
millénaires l'histoire de l'Europe même
si plus personne ne sait ce qui le
traité de Verdin ni ne se souvient de la
lotoringie c'est c'est qui a disparu
dans le dans les des soubrosau de
l'histoire
et et donc on va on va on va faire on va
dire voilà les frontières elles sont
intangibles alors c'est une mesure qu'on
on peut considérer c'est une mesure
conservatoire mais ça devient le droit
droit international c'est les frontières
que qui sont issues de ces traits qu'on
a tiré sur des cartes euh sans trop se
soucier de de leur
euh des conséquences et des réalités euh
deviennent le droit
bon on va faire la même chose euh quand
va s'effondrer l'Union soviétique
ou quand vont s'effondrer les empires
ion on va dire voilà les les on garde
les frontières administratives ou
coloniales
ou politiques qui ont été qui ont été
dessiné ell ne bouge plus voilà sinon B
il va y avoir des conflits partout euh
ça devient le droit international le
pilier du droit international donc
euh c'est c'est l'intangibilité des
frontières alors après elles peuvent
bouger si les peuples sont d'accord si
tout le monde est enfin si tout le monde
est d'accord sinon ça ça pe pas bouger
VO c'est cette idée de l'intangibilité
des frontières elle elle elle elle
commence là euh auparavant
euh tout le monde avait conscience que
les frontières bah elles bougeent en
fonction des rapports de force des des
victoires des défaites des bon des
invasions ou
euh des des des
revanches
euh et là on est dans la période où on
sacralise le droit international on le
le le droit international c'est plus
simplement le droit des traités c'est
c'est d'abord il faut bien comprendre
l'intangibilité des l'intangibilité des
frontières
euh on
va on va penser à ce moment-là que de
toute façon le droit peut résoudre tous
les problèmes voilà c'est c'est on va
mettre la guerre la
loi voilà la guerre et la loi c'est la
SDN le le proclame
euh on connaît la suite de l'histoire
c'est c'est
c'est aucune loi ne peut empêcher les
guerres
c'est donc à l'Arno en 1925 ben tout le
monde dit voilà les frontières
maintenant ce sont celles-là elles
bougeront plus
euhgal a une remarque d'ailleurs très
dans dans le fil de l'épée c'est
intéressante il dit bon bah faire
respecter le droit en général il faut il
faut une force militaire ou une force de
police ça RESPE il y en a il y en a pas
sur dans le domaine international et et
il dit croire qu'on va résoudre le
problème en disant c'est de loit c'est
c'est c'est une illusion il dit mais où
a-t-on vu que l'homme n'était plus
l'homme renvoie notre histoire de nature
de nature humaine
euh évidemment ça ça ça ne va pas
marcher c'estàdire que
euh la société allemande qui a beaucoup
souffert qui a été humiliée c'est euh
elle va elle va finir par faire ce que
font toutes les sociétés qui sonti
malades de cette façon qui
sont qui souffrent elle
elle elle va elle va résoudre ses
problèmes par la par la violence par le
la recherche de Bou émissaire pour pour
pour apaiser ses tensions interne et
pour se réunifier par rapport à
l'extérieur et elle a elle va appeler
l'hitlerérisme c'est c'est c'est pas
Hitler et c'est pas les nazis qui vont
nazifier l'Allemagne c'est c'est la
société allemande qui va appeler quelque
chose qui qui va finir par qui va être
le nazisme alors après là là-dessus le
le nazisme va s'installer s'organiser
mais mais c'est la société allemande
telle que nous
l'avons nous l'avons faite nous les
vainqueurs de de de 1900 de
1918 euh qui va appeler le qui va
appeler le le le nazisme et on voit bien
il d'abord il est pas raisonnable quand
quand la guerre est finie de vouloir
punir l'adversaire avec lequel vous êtes
obligé de vivre parce que ce graphie est
là c'està dire bah la France peut
toujours punir l'Allemagne tu sais mais
elle est c'est son voisin voà ce que ce
que comprendront mieux euh les
vainqueurs de 1900 de 1945 il y aura une
période de dénazification mais euh c'est
c'est
la réconciliation
franco-allemande qui va devoir beaucoup
au général de Gaul et à desur elle est
fondée sur sur justement sur cette prise
de conscience que vous dé vous changez
pas la géographie et que vous changez
pas la nature humaine VO et et et deg
aura cette phrase merveilleuse en en
recevant ad nour et on est quelques
années après la guerre je les plaies
sont encore très
vives va dire sans rien oublié du passé
la France et l'Allemagne ont décidé de
regarder ensemble vers
l'avenir et on va fonder la la la
réunification la
la la réconciliation
franco-allemande vous savez sur cette
fameuse visite ù de reçoit chez lui
Colombé à
denoer et à partir de cette idée sans
rien oublier du passé la France
etallemagne ont décidé de regarder
ensemble vers
l'avenir ce qu'on a pas fait du tout en
en en 1919 1920 euh on a cherché à punir
on a eu voilà le résultat de de d'Illes
c'est je crois que c'est enfin c'est
Bernanos qui dit dans dans les grand
cimetière sous la lune il écrit en 1937
il
dit il dit que la
la le nazisme au fond c'est c'est c'est
le le le visage de la de la souffrance
et de l'humiliation allemande VO c'est
c'est de la société allemande c'est et
et il a il a raison voilà
c'est c'est c'est tellement artificiel
ça
euh on va arriver sur sur le le le sujet
qui mon avis est central dans le débat
dans le débat actuel mais
euh c'est c'est une très grande leçon
d'histoire qui va nous coûter 60
millions de
morts CIN de son d'histoire et et de
nature humaine voilà de de
ce que la quel est le but de la de la
politique quel est le but de la
diplomatie c'est d'éviter que nous
passions notre temps à nous entretuer
voilà ça c'était
avant c'est alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est que c'était avant quoi
quand il y avait encore des valeurs dans
nos diplomates
bah ils ont tout raté là ce momentl
c'est on n pas demandé enfin on n' pas
fait de la diplomatie on n pas fait de
la politique on n pas tenu compte
de la nature humaine de j'ai une
question à vous poser à votre avis
Stéphane séjourn où Gabriel il est
capable de me résumer ce que vous venez
de me résumer en une heure là je n'en
sais rien je sais pas ce qu'il a fait
des études et qui VO mais mais inéress
c'est c'est le regard qu' qu'on porte
c'est les leçons qu'on tire de de
l'histoire l'histoire c'est pas un
ornement c'est pas juste un ornement
d'esprit encore une fois l'histoire elle
nous apprend ce que nous sommes ce dont
nous sommes capables pour le meilleur et
pour le pire ce que nous ce que nous ne
pouvons ce qui est incontournable dans
notre dans dans dans notre condition
humaine incontournable c'est d'ailleurs
c'est voilà punissez punissez
l'Allemagne et et humilier l'Allemagne
écraser l'Allemagne peutre vous aurez un
jour à payer le prix de cette écrasement
parce que l'homme est ainsi fait pas que
et encore une fois vous pouvez pas
déménager hein voilà vous allez
déménager ni l'Allemagne ni la
France que il faut voir ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a fait en se en ne faisant pas la
la politique à partir des réalités alors
on a créé très bien on a créé la
tchéchoslovaquie on lui a rattaché les
sudettes 3 million d'Allemands dans les
sudettes et la técoslovaquie était un
état
artificiel tellement d'ailleurs
artificiel qu'il n'existe plus alors il
s'est il s défit de façon pacifique mais
les Slovaques ont repris leur le leur
indépendance et les tchqus ont pris la
leure après la la période la période
communiste c'est c'est donc cet état qui
avait été créé qui nous a qui a été une
cause importante des des
des des tensions de de l'entre de
guerre n'existe plus il n'existe plus
parce qu'il était totalement artificiel
la youoslavie qui
mélangerrement les Serbes les Croates
les Bosniaques n'existe plus et elle
elle s'est défaite dans la douleurin
voilà dans la guerre civile ça c'est les
créations de la des des euh des traités
de la de la Première Guerre mondiale euh
et alors on en vient à
cette à cette période qui nous qui pour
moi permet de de
d'illustrer quelque chose de de encore
une fois de de de très profond qui nous
renvoie encore au début de notre
conversation euh qui est la la dimension
tragique de de l'histoire et de la
condition humaine
le
le qu'est-ce que le le tragique le
tragique c'est c'est d'abord la
confrontation
de de l'homme quand il veut
agir à sa propre à sa propre nature et à
sa nature violente
que la liberté d'agir elle se
paye
de d'un d'un prix qui est fixé par la
nature humaine le son la violence oui
c'estàdire c'est c'est il y
a il y a rien de
de si vous voulez agir vous vous ne
pouvez pas vous exonérer de regarder en
face ce ce de regarder en face le le le
tragique c'est-à-dire les conséquences
euh de de vos actes compte tenu de ce
qui est la nature de l'homme
c'est-à-dire sa sa violence intrinsèque
[Musique]
euh il y a deux façons d'aborder ce ce
ce ce ce problème c'est soit on
élude cette cette confrontation à à la à
la à la nature humaine à la nature
violente de de l'homme ça s'appelle la
bonne conscience
j'ai
j'ai il y pas de problème ça ça j'ai
j'ai lu de complètement j'occulte
complètement cette dimension viente soit
la regarder en face ça s'appelle le cas
de
conscience il compte tenu de ce que nous
sommes il n'est pas possible
d'agir ça ve dire moralement s sans le
déchirement de la
conscience c'est le prix à payer pour
notre liberté
d'agir ah c'est je
je je m'explique c'est
c'est l'homme en général la politique en
particulier est sans cesse confronté au
dilemme
tragique les dilèes tragiqu c'est le
contraire de maniquéisme du bien et du
mal je suis le bien
donc bien peut tout se permettre puis
qu'il est le
bien il est il est hors de question de
se prononcer sur ce que le bien peut
peut peut déclencher de de de violence
de de faire couler de sang voilà je je
et l'autre en face c'est le mal c'est
très commode il a plus de responsabilité
c'est c'est la
responsabilité la responsabilité qui est
le le corelire de la liberté disparaît
disparait complètement je je je je cite
souvent cet exemple
euh qui est qui est
euh l'épisode que relate René Charles le
poète qui on pendant la 2è guerre
mondiale est chefs de
Maqui et il raconte qu'un matin il
est avec ses maquisars sur les hauteurs
d'un
village en bas les Allemands viennent
arrêter euh un de leurs camarades qui
est caché dans le village enfin qui
était caché et euh il dit tous les
regards autour de moi m'implore de
donner l'ordre de tirer de là où on est
les Allemands savent pas qu'on est là on
peut tous les tuer on peut tous les
abattre et je n'ai pas donné l'ordre il
dit je n'ai pas donné l'ordre parce
que déchirement de la de de de la
conscience si je l'avais donné nous
aurions tué les Allemands nous aurions
sauvé notre camarade les Allemands
seraient revenus auraient massacrer le
village ça c'est un déchirement quel qu
que soit la finalement la solution que
vous allez
adopter ça c'est le déchirement de la
conscience
c'estàdire ne pas considérer
que au fond je ne suis concerné que
par la la mort des Allemands et la
libération de mon de notre
camarade du
maizard non je suis en prenant cette
décision j'engage aussi si ma
responsabilité morale au sens plus élevé
du terme vis-à-vis de tout le
village face à la guerre quand on quand
quand on nous dit c'est le bien c'est
c'est le Bien et le Mal
euh c'est exactement comme si René Char
s'était dit bon les Allemands ils
meurent mais il avent qu' pas être là
c'est après tout c'est eux qui sont
venus c'est des salots des nazis et des
en ur euh donc les tuer c'est bien
libérer mon camarade c'est bien le
village c'est pas mon problème c'est les
Allemands qui vont tuer le village les
Allemands sont responsables moi j'ai pas
de responsabilité dans cette affaire hé
là je sais qu'ils vont tuer les qui vont
venir massacré le village donc la morale
c'est j'ai une responsabilité quelle que
soit la soluation que je prne j'ai une
responsabilité euh soit je prends la
responsabilité de laisser mon camarade
mourir et c'est soit je prends la
responsabilité
mais elle est réelle de laisser
massacrer le village on peut pas peut
pas s'en échapper en se disant en disant
mais c'est pas grave c'est pas
moi ce n'est pas moi
son c'est voilà c'est tout le discours
ambiant récurrent sur ce
sujet tourneour de cette idée quoi c'est
c'est bah s massacre le village sont t
les responsables et pas MOI et admettre
la tragédie c'est c'est au contraire
dire bah je suis responsable aussi de
ça et alors le le on arrive au au cœur
de notre débat public
d'aujourd'hui vous avez nous a pas
échappé que il tourne autour de de une
fois de
plus de
Munich alors il y a peu de gens c'est
c'est très intéressant peu de gens
savent ce qui
munique et pourtant c'est au cœur du
débat
VO alors munique c'est c'est quoi c'est
l'accord que vont passer
les les Français les Anglais les
Italiens et les Allemands à propos des
sudettes dont on vient de parler
euh qui les Français et les Anglais
reconnaissent le droit pour les allemand
euh de d'annexer les sudettes à
l'Allemagne al je répète quand mêmef il
y avait 3 millions il y avait 3 millions
d'Allemands et c'est resté dans
l'imaginaire
collectif conscient ou inconscient
d'ailleurs comme l'exemple type de la
lâcheté des démocraties de où nous
conduit la lâcheté
elle nous conduit à tout ce qui s'est
passé tout ce qui s'est passé ensuite on
a abandonné les les les Tchécoslovaques
à leur
sort en essayant de de sauver la paix
qu'on n pas sauvé alors on cite souvent
la phrase de Churchill qui l' pas
prononcé mais en réalité mais écrite
dans une lettre bien avant avant munique
vous aurez vous aurez à la fois la
défaite et le déshonneur bon voilà donc
vous pouvez pas dire un mot sur sur ce
conflit sans qu'on vous lance à la
figure
munique alors vous êtes attendez qui
vous lance quoi qui lance bah tout le
monde enfin tout B tous ceux qui pensent
que c'est c'est le combat du bien contre
le mal euh et que de toute façon en face
on a un dictateur
euh si vous si si vous évoquez la la la
la possibilité de de négocier
de pour essayer d'arrêter cette cette
guerre vous êtes munii c'est-à-dire vous
êtes comme euh vous êtes comme
Chamberlin premier ministre anglais de
l'époque et et et d'adier le président
du Conseil français de de cette époque
c'est une lâcheté euh et vous vous vous
vous préparez au vous avez le déshonneur
et vous aurez la défaite c'està dire
prenez le risque
euh que que qu'ils ont pris
de en en donnant à Hitler cette
cette donnant à Hitler les sudettes de
le voir dévorer tout ce qui sera sur son
passage voilà pariant sur la faiblesse
évidemment des des
démocraties alors ça mérite qu'on qu'on
qu'on s'y arrête à inst c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est oublié toute la
dimension tragique de C de cet épisode
c'est oublieré
que d'abord il y a une candidate il y a
pas longtemps dans les élections
européennes qui a dit vous savez madame
Le Pen c'est c'est Daladier je sais
plus qui c'est c'est s Berlin bon
euh s'est fait rappeler à l'ordre par
quelques historiens qui en avaient un
peu assez mais
euh si vous prononcez ces deux nom c'est
c'est la lâcheté c'est l'incarnation de
la lâcheté de la aucun des deux n'était
ni lâche ni stupide ni ni faible
euh
mais pour les Anglais et pour une bonne
partie de la droite française de
l'époque euh
entre les le péril nazi et le péril
communiste le péril nazi était moins
dangereux mieux vaut les mieux vaut
Hitler que que Staline mieux vaut Hitler
que les rouges voilà euh ça c'était la
la première chose et et les Anglais
menaçaient constamment de de de rompre
l'alliance avec la France qui aurait
été une catastrophe pour la pour la
France si euh
euh si on ne pratiquait pas une
politique d'apaisement vis-à-vis de
d'Hitler la HTI de chamber des
conservateurs anglais c'était la la la
révolution bolchevique partout en Europe
voilà la question s'est d'ailleurs posée
avant Munich à propos de la guerre
d'Espagne Bloom qui n'était ni un lâche
ni un
imbécile s'est trouvé confronté un ce
dilemme tragique est-ce que je vais
aider les républicains espagnols contre
contre les
franquistes ce vers quoi tout le pousser
puisque à la tête du Front populaire euh
socialiste groupant les socialistes et
et les communistes euh son cœur son son
âme son son ses
engagements le le pousser tout
naturellement à à intervenir en Espagne
au côté des républicains sauf que les
premièrement les les Anglais menacai de
quitter l'alliance avec la France parce
qu'il ne voulaient pas de la de la de la
de la victoire des des anarchistes des
des
staliniens en Espagne toujours la la
peur de la révolution bolchevique en
Europe et puis parce que B vous me
sentez très bien qu'il y avait aussi un
risque de conflagration de
conflagration
européenne et que à torou a
raison personne ne ne se en France en
particulier ne se ne se pensait
militairement en mesure de soutenir une
une guerre de ce genre euh
donc Bloom va va va dire non va va il va
aider en sousmain les les les
républicain
espagnol les Français qui sont allés les
aider sont partis dans les Brigades
internationales mais mais pas pas sous
uniforme français et et encore une fois
Bloom nétait pas un lâche c'est c'est il
fera d'ailleurs un grand discours pour
expliquer pourquoi il qui peut peut pas
y aller qui prendra pas cette
responsabilité discutit un jour avec un
philosophe sur un plateau de de de
cetteuron qui revenait encore sur Munich
sur achétait on parle de Blue mais il me
dit oui mais il l'a regretté toute sa
vie et j'ai répondu
oui
heureusement heureusement parce parce
que ça a été un déchirement de la
conscience parce que il a pas passer par
pertes et profils et les les les
victimes de la guerre
civile oui il a regretté mais ça c'est
le c'est le c'est le c'est le propre de
la conscience tragique c'estd je prends
une décision je sais que dans certaines
certain de circonstances quelle que soit
la décision que je prends
j'aurais des victimes sur les sur du
sang sur les mains ou
de ou des des des souffrances dont je
serai je créerai des souffrances don je
dont je suis dont je suis responsable
aussi et donc c'est voilà ça prouve que
bah ça prouve que Bloom avait une
conscience
oui il l'a regretté et il a fait ce
choix dans le déchirement de la
conscience parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
c'est ce que nous apprend aussi la la la
tragédie antique hein
c'est il n'y a pas d'action de choix
face au dilemmes tous les dilemmes
tragiques de la vie euh qui n'entraîne
en même temps un sentiment de
culpabilité quand on a une
conscience la conscience chez les hommes
politiques au 21e siècle ben pas
beaucoup alors sûrement chez certains
mais en tout cas dans ce qu'on dans ce
qu'on voit il y a
une et ceux qui en ont ont une capacité
à la à la mettre sous le Boissau qui est
qui est face à des à des enjeux comme ce
auquel nous sommes confrontés qui est
quand même quand même étonnante je moi
je je faire de procès d'intention à
personne
mais cette cette présentation maniquenne
du Bien contre le Mal
c'est le contraire de la de la de la
morale en politique la morale en
politique encore une fois c'est le cas
de conscience et pas la bonne conscience
c'est c'est
revenant revenant à à
1938 revenant à
Munich c'est intéressant de voir ce qui
s'est ce qui s'est passé à ce moment
d'abord tout était jouer à ce
moment-là si on voulait pas Hitler il
fallait pas traiter la société allemande
cette façon si on voulait se débarrasser
d'hitar il fallait le faire plutôt
euh en 35 c'était la fin de la de
la de l'occupation de la Sare il y a eu
un référendum que les nazis ont gagné on
donc réoccupé la ça et puis il y a eu la
mais en 36 début 36 il y a la
remilitarisation de
laarenaniie et là c'était une violation
de traité de Versailles euh c'est le
gouvernement français déclare nous ne
laisserons pas Strasbourg à la portée
des canons allemands et que fait-on rien
et là l'armée allemande n'était pas
encore ce qu'elle allait devenir
quelques quelques temps plus tard elle
était en pleine reconstruction
mais on fait début
1936 on fait tellement rien que tous les
alliés de la France en Europe se dit si
même quand c'estes les intérêts vitaux
des des Français sont à ce point en jeu
ils ne font rien ils font certainement
rien en pour venir nous aider si on est
attaqué par les par les par les
Allemands bon en
1938 d'abord on a réarmé très tard c'est
c'est le Front populaire qui commence à
réarmer euh donc fin 1936 début 1937 ça
ressemble un peu à ce qu'on vit en ce
moment non mais ça ressemble
tellement il y a en 1935 le le le
président du conseil donc avant la
remilitarisation de la re
euh le président du conseil de l'époque
qui s'appelle Pierre Laval alors c'est
pas encore le Laval de la la
collaboration hein c'est l' Homme
politique comme un autre plutôt
pacifiste mais et surtout
très très très porté sur
euh sur l'orthodoxie
financière il a il restera célèbre assez
célèbre dans l'histoire pour avoir mis
en place pour répondre à la la
crise à la grande crise une politique de
déflation où on baisse autoritairement
les salaires les revenus bon
et qui va rester espèce d'épouvantail
dans l'histoire de des politiques
économiques
et un jour la la commission des finances
du Sénat va va avoir enfin demande avoir
le président Laval commission parlant de
la défense du Sénat ouais et c'est c'est
Alfred sovi qui a écrit
une série de livres sur l'histoire
économique de la France entre les deux
guerres qui le raconte
euh en présence de du président
Laval le président de la commission lui
dit monsieur le Président il faut
réarmer et le président Laval répond ah
mes chers amis je le voudrais
bien mais la situation financière de la
France ne le permet
pas voilà donc on a perdu
on a perdu encore du temps et un temps
extrêmement précieux dans le pour le
pour le réarmement et et ça a coûté
infiniment plus mais situation
financière en c'est ce qu'on entend
de depuis des années un général un jour
sur sur un plateau le le qui était sur
un plateau le le
présentateur regarde les statistiques et
dit c'est c'est quand même
extraordinaire on a on a on a que 200
chars alors qu'avant on en a avait euh
1200 moi quand j'ai fait mon s sm il y
Ava eu 1200 char c'est pas les mêmes les
amx30 c'était pas la même chose que les
euh vous étiz chef de char pendant votre
service j'étais pas chef de char j'étais
dans un régiment de char euh je
commandais ce qu'on appelait un peu le T
pé ça ça n'existe plus dans nos régiment
de char il y avait un un un escadron de
de de pé c'est-à-dire c'était des des
blindés plus légers mais à chenille
aussi qui qui accompagnent le régiment
de de de de char il y
avait donc une une compagnie avec avec
trois
plutons qui avait chacun trois chars
voilà moi je commandais un peu le ton de
un peu le ton de char c'était de c'était
des amx10 à Cheny
euh dire qu'il y avait une une trentaine
de de une trentaine d'hommes à commander
ce qui était c'était le c'est céit très
utile pour un régiment de chararme on
déà supprimé pour des raisons d'économie
ensuite euh c'était le le c'était
l'unité qui en cas de guerre à haute
intensité avait la la la plus faible la
plus faible durée de de de vie voilà en
qui était censé avoir la plus faible
durée de la plus faible durée de vie et
le réarmement et le
le et donc le le sur le plateau dit
quand même c'est bien 200 CHS on a 200
chats sachant que sur les 200 il y en a
100 qui pour les pièces bah qui March
pas parce que comme on a
pas on a on est resté à ce à cet éage et
on n pas renouvelé le matériel il y en a
100 qui servent à fournir des pièces
pour et alors journaliste tourne vers le
général mais comment comment est-ce
possible il y a un blanc général laisse
tomber pas d'argent
voilà de de du président Laval en
1935 aux années 90
2000 rien rien n'a changé c'est c'est
pourtant l'histoire nous apprend des ch
c'est pas qu'elle se répète encore une
fois c'est que les les nos nos façons
d'affronter les les les les problèmes
notre nature enfin nous nous nous
répétons sans arrêt voilà c'est c'est on
finit 3945 et on enchaîne sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment o on finit sur on va
enchaîner avec avec 1930 toujours avec
1938 si ça vous ennuie pas parce que ce
Ce à ce moment-là les choses sont donc
en grande partie joué et elles se sont
joué chaque fois avec des en face de
dilemmees tragiques qui ont été plus ou
moins bien résolu donc la guerre
d'Espagne mais aussi la la la question
de l'Éthiopie faut faut se souvenir
quand même que musolini n'aimait pas du
tout n'aimait pas Hitler que la première
tentative chous en 34 monie envoie ses
divisions sur le col du braenner pour
dissuader Hitler de de d'envahir
l'Autriche puis en 35 missini qui veut
se tailler lui aussi un empire colonial
attaque la attaque la la l'Éthiopie et
euh il est condamné par la cté des
nations la France
l'Angleterre Prenn parti pour
l'Éthiopie c'est il l'époque du Négus
qui vient faire un grand discours très
épouvant d'ailleurs à la la Société des
Nations et là c'est on est dans PRS
dilemme tragique c'est-à-dire que euh
évidemment le le le le le sort de
l'Éthiopie est émouvant et il est il est
normal qu'on ait envie de de les aider
mais en prenant le parti de l'Éthiopie
qui finira après après un long après de
longs combats parce que l'armée
italienne n'est pas très efficace à
l'époque mais euh finira par succomber
le
le solini se tourne se tourne vers
Hitler et celle celle l'alliance avec
avec Hitler alors est-ce qu'on a eu tort
ou raison c'est c'est pas le problème
mais en tout cas c'est on là encore le
dilemme tragique ne pouvait pas être
être éludé
oui je devrais aider l'Éthiopie mais oui
mais si je le fais
h Mussolini va se jeter dans les bras
d'Hitler ce qui ce qui sait
effectivement ce qui s'est ce qui s'est
passé et en 38
il faut savoir que cette cette
conférence de Munich elle est pas
demandée par Hitler Hitler ne n'attend
pas du tout l'autorisation des Anglais
et des Français pour pour prendre des
sudettes Hitler a fait ses plans il a
pris le commandement de l'armée tout est
prêt pour envahir les sudettes ce sont
les Français les Anglais qui demandent à
Mussolini de faire l'intermédiaire pour
pour qu' pour qu'il y ait une conférence
sur les sur les sur les sudê
euh il faut savoir que aller aider les
aller aider les
tchqus à résister aux Allemands c'était
pour les Français et les Anglais
militairement impossible ah c'est alors
peut-être qu'on a sous-évalué peut-être
qu'on aurait pu attaquer l'Allemagne
pendant qu'ils étaient dans les mais moi
j'ai regardé tous
les enfin les notes des chefs militaires
et ce que disent les chefs militaires au
politique c'est ben non on peut pas le
chef de le chef étatmajor de l'armée de
l'air il dit ah bah non on a pas on est
encore trop en retard sur les Allemands
on peut rien euh on sait pas comment
acheminer les des troupes là-bas le
Gamelin qui est le chef d'état-major
général des armées dit de toute façon
les les les les tchèqus ne ne pourront
pas résister assez longtemps pour que
qu'on puisse les aider bref euh c'est
impossible alors la la la France va
essayer va va tenter une autre une autre
une autre solution la solution la France
en 35 a signé un qu'un accord une
alliance avec la Russie de enfin l'ion
soviétique
euh une alliance militaire que qui plaît
pas du tout aux Anglais hein évidemment
qui qui faont tout faire pour qu'elle ne
se concrétise jamais mais
euh le le quand commence à se dessiner
la crise la crise des
sudettes le le gouvernement français
demande à son ambassadeur à
Varsovie si euh il accepte si les
Polonais accepterait de laisser passer
l'Armée rouge pour aller aider les pour
aller aider les les
tchèqus réponse des des Polonais qui que
l'ambassadeur s'appelait Léon Noël
a a transcrit dans ses Mémoires réponse
des Polonais
euh comprenez C les Allemands sont des
adversaires mais euh les Russes mais au
moins ils sont européens les Russes sont
des barbares et des asiatiques et donc
entre les deux choisira pas les
on veut pas les laisser passer voilà
c'est c'est une vieille histoire là
encore c'est compréhensible hein c'est
c'est les fantômes qui entent les les
les esprits en en Pologne vis-à-vis de
de la Russie ils sont ils sont toujours
là ils sont mais ils étaient là à ce
moment-là aussi donc impossible de faire
passer les Roumains ne voulaient pas
davantage pour d'autres raisons ben il y
a pas moyen d'aller d'aller aider les
les les les tchqus donc donc c'est pas
une c'est pas une lâcheté c'est que à ce
moment là c'est une impossibilité
d'ailleurs Churchill le dira dans un Mo
après il y a un discours Mo après Munich
un discours devant la Chambre des
communes et en fait c'est pas faut pas
se polariser sur cet événement c'est
l'aboutissement de plusieurs années
d'aveuglement d'abord parce qu'on a on
n' pas réarmé l'Angleterre encore moins
que la
France était le seul à dire il faut
réarmer parce que il dangereux les
autres disaient non il faut tirer les
dividendes de la paix
puis et et il dit voilà tout s joué tout
s joué avant on avait fait des pour
former des systèmes d'allian on avait on
avait créé une alliance s'appelait La
Petite entente qui avait été organisée
par le essenciellement par les Français
qui
regroupaient la Roumanie la
Tchécoslovaquie et puis la Yougoslavie
bonah voilà ça c'est fini ça va pas
parce que ils ont plus conf ils savent
que de toute façon on les aidera pas
mais en septembre
1938 on ne pouvait pas ou tout au moins
on pensait ne pas pouvoir
aider de pas pouvoir aider la
tchcoslovaquie militairement ça c'est
d'ailleurs repassé ensuite avec la
Finlande on avait promis à la Finlande
qu'on aiderait les AM même les
Américains l'avaient promis puis on a
laissé la Finlande se débrouiller avec
Staline
bon et la Pologne
B faut savoir que quand hutler a pris un
des a pris les sudettes la Pologne a
pris un petit bout de la Tchécoslovaquie
quand même qu'elle revendiquait depuis
longtemps qui est morceau de la Silésie
s'appelait le le le district de Tchen
c'est où il y avait 300000 300000
polonais qui étaient un voilà il y avait
eu un arbitrage pour tracer la frontière
qui plaisait pas au Polonais on a
profité pour prendre un bout bon et puis
euh bah puis l'année suivante on sait ce
qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire que les
Allemands et les et les les Soviétiques
sachant que de toute façon mant ils
étaient tout seuls face à à l'Allemagne
euh puisque les Occidentaux voulaient
pas de de de leur alliance
euh on fait le traité le pacte
germano-soviétique il sont partagé la
Pologne nous avons déclaré la guerrefin
la France et l'Angleterre ont déclaré la
guerre à l'Allemagne comme elle l'avait
comme elle l'avait
euh elle l'avait promis mais on n'est
pas allé en
Allemagne c'est là que se situe
l'épisode de la drôle de guerre dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure euh la drôle
de guerre c'est que on déclare la guerre
Allemagne et on et on reste derrière la
ligne
maginau on a assisté au démantellement
de la Pologne voilà euh sans sans sans
bouger un petit doigt on a attendu que
Hitler c'est pour n'est pas aller
chercher les Allemands chez eux hein il
attendu qu'il viennent chez nous al il
aait beaucoup à dire d'ailleurs sur
cette cette histoire vous savez ils
passeront pas par les
Ardennes mais ce qui est fantastique et
qu'on qu'on sait pas en général c'est
que c'est que nous savions très bien
qu'il pouvait passer par les Ardennes il
y avait eu plusieurs exercices
militaires qui avaient été qui avait été
qui avait été fait de
depuis début des années 30 jusqu'en 1938
et qui montrait que les Allemands
pouvaient passer alors au début on s'est
dit pas grave parce que c'était encore
l'armée d'armistice enfin c'est encore
l'armée
de l'armée du traité de Versailles ils
avaient pas de moyens et cetera mais à
partir de 33 on change pas d'avis hein
c'est c'est on fait un exercice en 34 en
38 euh mais comme ça correspondait pas à
l'idée qu'on se faisait de ce de ce
qu'allaiit faire les Allemands
euh et ben on on a on a on a rien fait
pour pour parer à cette éventualité
voilà c'est quand même alors qu'on
savait qu'il pouvait passer on avait
même chronométré le temps qu'il mettrait
pour passer
euh c'est c'est c'est voilà c
extraordinaire la cécité
euh que que on peut parfois avoir quand
quelque chose dérange nos plans
préétablis la cité des politiques ou des
militaires des militaires dégradés bah
oui des état-major enfin des des
étatmajur le le Gamelin avait son plan
ça correspondait pas à son
plan et donc ça pouvait pas arriver en
on a pris aucune mesure et on savait on
savait que si si combien de temps il
mettrait pour franchir les les les
ardenes et et et combien de temps il
faudrait pour amener des pour amener des
des des renforts s'il faisait ça et et
et combler la brèche euh et le résultat
c'était qu'il serait parti il serait
très arrivé déjà très très loin avant
qu'on ait pu on ait pu amener les
troupes nécessaires pour pour combler la
brèche et cela arrivé donc euh c'est
voilà il y a tout ça est dans les
archives militaires c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est assez
extraordinaire et
donc 1938 c'est c'est c'est c'est
historiquement en réalité un mauvais
exemple les gens dont on parle ne sont
pas des lâches mais il faut voir ce
qu'on en a
fait quand on diuni quoi on dit pas
seulement pas seulement
d'adier la politique d'apaisement avec
AC s
Berlin c'est pas seulement une forme
d'aveuglement ou de de lâcheter c'est
quand on dit muniois on dit aussi
collabo voilà c'est c'est muniis c'est
c'est col be parce que les gens qui
étaient les plus les plus promuniques
ont finit souvent dans la
collaboration et et donc aujourd'hui
c'est euh on commence par vous dire
muniko munikois sous-entend en général
Marcel DEA qui est un des des pires
collaborateur de la de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale qui avait été qui venait du
parti socialist enfin de la SFIO à
l'époque
euh qui était plus collaborateur que
Vichy hein
c'était avait
de de les deux grands leaders de la
collaboration la pire Marcel DEA qui
venait du SFIO donc du socialisme et
puis d'Orio qui venait du Parti
communiste et et donc vous êtes déjà à
Marcel DEA quoi c'est c'est il y a y a
plus possible c'est fait à desin c'est
fait à desin c'estàd que quand on vous
compare à pour vous empoisonner votre
réputation c'est fait à dessin oui bien
sûr mais c'est fait mais mais tout ça
c'est inclu dans le le bien contre le
mal et on va ça va très loin c'est des
gens qui ne connaissent pas l'histoire
ou ils la connaissent tellement bien
qu'il veulent vous très bien mais c'est
comme ça c'est c'est
euh c'est c'est s'agit s'agit pas de
débattre il s'agit de
disqualifier par association oui par
association alors il se trouve que
Marcel DEA avait écrit avant la guerre
un livre qui sappelit mourir pour
dzig on rappelait tout à l'heure à la
ville avec son couloir pour expliquer
qu'il voulait voulait pas mourir que la
français devit pas mourir pour DZ donc
si vous voulez pas mourir pour pour pour
l'Ukraine vous êtes un marcel da voilà
c'est c'est pour eux c'est c'est euh et
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça c'est pas ça ça ça commence pas avec
avec le débat ressant de depuis
1938 cette cette cette image de 1938 euh
de la lâcheté de l'aveuglement euh voire
de la de la de la collaboration euh elle
est dans dans toutes les dans tous les
commentairirees sur les relations
internationales ça commence d'ailleurs
très tôt ça commence en 1950 avec la
guerre de Corée où
euh on voit des articles sur si on si on
cède là c'est c'est munique faut éviter
munique
asiatique on reverra ça avec le Vietnam
he Munich asiatique encore
euh on verra cette cette on reverra
cette cette C cette cette image enfin
cette référence euh avec la
youoslavie ceux qui qui qui prodent
Munich ou qui prêchent mun Munich est-ce
que vous avez fait un peu l'organigramme
quel courant politique de quel pays
venait alors les pays les pays c'est
c'est vrai dans tout l'Occident c'est
vrai en France en particulier c'est vrai
en Angleterre c'est vrai aux États-Unis
aux
États-Unis c'était un polthologue
Américain dit c'est le c'est le c'est
munique c'est le c'est le le c'est le
cri du parti de la guerre du part de la
guerre de la de la guerre ininterrompue
c'est toujours munique hein c'est voilà
faites pas ça si vous allez pas si vous
allez pas en Irak pour renverser Saddam
Hussein c'est munique sous-entendu vous
êtes un aveugle un lâche un collabo si
vous n'allez pas en Afghanistan vous
occupez pasghanistan pendant un temps
c'est
munique ça c'est c'est ainsi il y a le
parti de la guerre de la guerre
permanente utilise toujours il se
reconnaît à ça c'est
que c'est c'est c'est munique en 99
quand on bombarde la on bombarde la
la la Serbie
euh régist de bris fait un voyage en
Serbie et
euh il revient et il dit bah ce que j'ai
vu c'est pas exactement ce qu'on dit il
se fait
lincher par toute la
presse un philosophe toujours en pointe
dans ce genre de linchage va même écrire
bien sûr régiste de Bré n'est pas
dilleux et Belgrade n'est pas Berlin
drilleux drilleux la Rochel qui a lui
aussi était un collaborateur mais pour
une
suspension voilà c'est c'est un
philosophe qu'on connaitt tous oui pas
mais c'est dans le monde he c'est pas
voilà c'est pas une c'est pas une parole
en l'air c'est une parole écrite
et mais c'est extraordinaire les les la
façon dont les choses se corr ondre on
va on va bombarder la la et renverser le
régime de miloevic qui qui qui est un
dictateur mais on va le faire parce que
on on va on va raconter n'importe quoi
sur les chiffr des des des
massacres et puis les Allemands vont
faire vont s faire fuiter un plan
d'puration ethnique
euh soi-disant conçu par au Kosovo conçu
par les par les Serbes dont on se rendra
compte quelques années après que c'était
un faux et les journaux d'ailleurs qui
l'avait repris onont présenter des
excuse mais bien des années plus tard
euh comme la production d'rax en Irak
c'est la même chose et c'est la même
chose alors en Irak c'était c'est pas
aussi délibéré pour pour pour l'histoire
de la Serbie mais du Kosovo mais en Irak
euh c'est c'est C délibéré c'est un état
et pas n'importe lequel qui qui
délibérément va mentir au monde au monde
entier euh et c'est toujours vous vous
vous êtes contre c'est munique bon alors
euhut faut se souvenir de ce que Chirac
a entendu comment enfin d'insulte
d'accusation de de d'ailleurs les gens
qui ont qui ont été les plus en pointe
euh pour condamner pour condamner la la
France enfin l'attitude de de de Chirak
en ira pour expliquer qu'il fallait y
aller à tout prix que
c'était ils sont encore ils sont encore
dans le débat indéboulonnable voilà donc
je citerai personne non plus mais quand
même quoi c'était et c'était pareil
c'était si on l'arrête pas il s'arrêtera
pas voilà ça a coûté probablement dans
dans la durée au moins un million de
morts des millions de réfugiés
euh
daesh plus les réfugiés qui sont allés
se noyer dans la Méditerranée enfin
c'est c'est c'est c'est la la
la le chaos dans ce dans ce pays qui
n'arrive pas à se réconcilier parce
qu'on a réouvert les les évidemment les
les les les fractures entre les chiites
les
sunites chaos absolu qui qui don qu'on
arrive toujours pas d'ailleurs à à
régler VO mais sinon c'était
munique c'était qu'est-ce qui a fait
tenir Chirac après ce qui qu'est-ce qui
a fait tenir Chirac c'est vous c'est
Villepin c'est son équipe c'est ses serv
c'est lui qui a c'est lui tout seul he
il était bien renseigné quand même à
l'époque on avait des services de
renseignement en
pointe peut-être que nos renseignements
était était meilleur il y avait quand
même il y avait un doute sur sur sur sur
sur tout ça voilà c'est et et surtout
c'était ce que ce que le père de George
bouche n'avait pas de George bouche
Junor n'avait pas fait quand il y avait
eu la guerre du Golfe il s'était arrêté
aux frontières de l'Irak voà le fils
poussé par un entourage euh de c'est
toujours pareil de de vatanguerre de
faucon de
de aller renverser le régime c'est euh
euh c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est cette cette idée
que
que l'Occident peut-être le le gendarme
du monde c'est le camp du Bien c'est euh
oui c'était un Tiran
sanguinaire Sadam Hussein et la question
est de savoir si on a décidé euh de
d'aller tuer tous les tyrans sanguinaire
dans dans dans le me dans le monde
entier de faire la guerre tout le temps
à tout le monde c'est c'est voilà c'est
dire euh le résultat était un
désastre désastre géopolitique un
désastre humain euh parce que la guerre
c'est c'est c'est pas quelque chose avec
lequel on joue enfin c'est c'est encore
une fois on ouvre
le on on ouvre toutes les vannes de la
violence de la pire violence et c'est un
engrenage l'engrenage qui conduit à la
guerre puis y a l'engrenage de la guerre
elle-même qui est toujours une montée
aux extrêmes où on finit par faire des
par commettre des crimes des massacres
dont on aurait jamais pensé qu'on était
capable de les commettre jamais voilà et
c'est cherché au début de la guerre il
dis nous on fait la guerre au militaire
pas au civil souvenez comment on finit
la Seconde Guerre mondiale par le
bombardement des villes allemandes avec
des bombes incendiaires et des c'est
chaque nuit des dizaines de milliers de
gens brûl vif VO c'est c'est comment a
fini la la la la guerre au la guerre au
Japon bombardement de Tokyo c'est 100000
morts avant avant avant les deux avant
les deux les deux bombes les deux bombes
àomique si on avait dit à Truman
quelques années avant qu'il allait faire
ça il aurait jamais il n'aurait jamais
pensé que c'était possible d'ailleurs il
fera pas la même chose en Corée quand
McArthur voudra déclarer la guerre à la
Chine parce que les Chinois voit des des
des des des des centaines de milliers de
de volontaires pour aider la Corée du
Nord euh que maarthur veut porter la
guerre sur le sol chinois et veut même
utiliser l'arme nucléaire voudrait
utiliser l'arme nucléaire contre la
Chine et là trumman dira non parce que
c'est c'est c'est c'est trop
risqué mais il faut une sagesse vous AZ
par quand vous êtes confronté à cette
espèce de cet argument sur Munich
éternel argument sur Munich ça veut dire
que vous tout dictateur euh tout
adversaire tout ennemi et
Hitler donc si c'est Hitler
effectivement il y a pas de question à
se poser même si ça doit coûter des
millions de morts c'est Hitler bon si on
si si on le si on ne l'anéantit pas de
toute façon il est prêt à toutes
les il est prêt à toutes les apocalypses
donc si c'est Hitler il y a plus à
réfléchir il y a plus à se demander
comment il pense ce qu'il veut et penser
un instant qu'on peut arriver à à
trouver une solution à marchander une
solution politique voilà c'est c'est
c'est Hitler tellement dangereux c'est
il s'arrêtera effectivement nulle part
si si Poutine c'est Hitler ah bah il
faut accepter des millions de morts
parce que de toute façon il est prêt à
détruire la
planète c'est c'est si zig Jinping c'est
Hitler bah voilà c'est pareil hein il
faut faut les faire la guerre à la Chine
parce que voilà c'est c'est Hitler
Hitler ça puisque c'est Hitler il y a il
y a plus à réfléchir il y a a plus à
penser il a plus à se préoccuper de ce
que de des des ressorts qui sont qui qui
qui font agir l'autre he voilà c'est
Hitler euh et làdedans vous rajoutez le
droit
internationalouvez c'est extraordinaire
c'est alors le droit international c'est
quoi le droit international c'est les
frontières que Staline a dessiné à
l'intérieur de l'Union soviétique ou où
les les marchandes le fruit des
marchandages de crutchef pour avoir des
voies ukrainiennes au Comité central
comme la Crimée euh et alors et vous
prenez conscience de de les norm ité de
la chose de enfin de cet argument quand
vous regardez ce qui se passe en Arménie
entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan le haut
cararabak c'est c'est qu'aon fait du
droit au nom du droit international
c'est-à-dire de l'intangibilité des
frontières tracées par Staline entre les
deux pays on s'est assis sur le droit
d'un d'un peuple au kabakh qui est là
depuis presque 3000
ans voilà c'est
c'est donc le le le le droit
international c'est c'est pas la morale
universel VO c'est pas c'est c'est si ça
peut servir tant mieux si ça peut servir
pour nous pas pour eux mais mais pour
tout le monde de temp temps ça ça peut
servir à à éviter des conflits à bon
très bien je veux dire mais mais
mais c'est c'est pas sacré quoi c'est
pas
c'est ça peut même être totalement
immoral regardez ce c'était très
intelligent les les les les ceux qui ont
tiré les leçons de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale beaucoup plus que ceux qui ont
tiré les leçons de la première même s'il
y avait des
gens de très grande stature
euh
aujourd'hui plupart des gens considèrent
que le Conseil de sécurité
euh est une erreur
B parce que il y a des droits de vet des
grandes puissances donc donc c'est pas
bien il faut supprimer les droits de vé
voilà un tas de
gens qui pensent
ça deux gouvern de chefs de gouvernement
deun certain nombre de pays anglosaxons
enfin qui qui eux n'ont pas de droit de
véau et en réalité c'était la chose la
plus intelligente qu'on qui qui est
qu'on a conçu c'est pas dit ça ça
paralyse l'ONU mais ça fonctionne
exactement comme un disjoncteur en
électricité c'est-à-dire que ça nous a
évité le le fait de de de de de donner
des droits de vétoau aux grandes
puissances euh ça ça a marqué les ça a
permis marquer les limites de de de de
chacun et ces limites qui si elles
avaient été franchies auraient débouché
sur la trè guerre mondiale voilà voilà
c'est c'est exactement encore une fois
le principe du disjoncteur en
électricité quand ta tension est trop
forte il bon et ben il faut il faut ça
ça disjoncte voilà euh et donc c'est
très en réalité c'est c'est très
intelligent parce que ça part de la
réalité de la là encore de la nature
humaine
euh c'est les hommes étant ce qu'ils
sont les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
et bien il vaut mieux la la la la
paralysie que
que que transformer le Conseil de
sécurité en une espèce de
tribunal qui qui n'a pas qui n'aurait
pas d' enfin je que que de pour faire
respecter ces décisions de faire la
guerre mais faire la guerre à qui si
vous faites la guerre à la Serbie ça va
c'est facile mais la guerre à la Chine
la guerre à la Russie
la guerre au bloc soviétique au P de
Varsovie pendant la guerre froide c'est
autre chose on a traité aussi de l'âche
Kennedy m de l'affaire enfin certains de
l'affaire des fusé de
Cuba Kennedy comme comme Kennedy comme
krutchev était entouré aussi de de fauc
con de gens qui voulaient la
guerre et krutchev comme Kenedy ont
résisté à ces ces assez faucon
euh ils ont négocié ce
secrètement et finalement mononde s'en
est sorti sans perdre la sans perdre la
face et un an après Kenedy va faire un
discours à l'université de Washington où
il va expliquer ça il va dire que euh
c'est c'est extraordinairement dangereux
c'est un cercle vicieux très dangereux
de de mettre deux puissances nucléaires
en tenstion euh et qu'il faut trouver le
moyen de faire baisser attention sans
qu'aucun des deux ne perde la face et il
y a des gens qui ont plus sont qui ont
qui ont vomis sur sur Kennedy pour avoir
fait ce
discours mais c'était ça où
la la guerre mondial bon
euh on a retrouvé d'ailleurs toujours
pareil toujours cette histoire de
toujours toujours munique toujours la
lâcheté euh quand Obama refuse de de de
renverser le régime de de Bachar
al-Assad scandaleux c'est au dernier
moment dans les années 2014
mais le problème de l'Occident dilemme
tragique hein c'est que Bachar était
enfin le régime de Bachar est un régime
terrible
mais il était le dernier rempart contre
daesh donc la la la question était daesh
ou
ou daouachar dilème
tragique
bon moi je pense qu'il faut souvent
beaucoup plus de sagesse il en a fallu à
Truman pour pas déclencher la guerre
nucléaire à Kennedy pour la les fusées
de Cuba à Obama aussi pour pour ne
pas pour
pas pour pour pas rentrer dans le le le
le cycle le cercle vicieux là de du
renversement du c'est ce que ça ça c'est
ça a coûté partout où on a fait
ça c'est c'est bah il faut plus de
sagesse pour se pour se
retenir quand on est confronté à un
dilemme tragique de ce genre que que que
pour intervenir pour pour pour ne pas de
munioio c'est c'est on me dirait il y a
la Libye et la Libye c'est un cas
d'école c'est
c'est la Libye c'est sont des
responsables politiques notamment le
président français mais qui se trouve
confronté à un cas de conscience on leur
dit si vous si vous nous aidez pas il va
tuer tout le monde à benazi alors aur
peut-être pas tué tout le monde mais en
aurait tué beaucoup
euh personne à ce
moment-là même après avoir décidé
d'intervenir ne veut faire la
guerre le le et d'ailleurs ce ce qu'on
obtient du Conseil de sécurité c'est
euh
la sécurisation voouà c'est l'espace
c'est c'est c'est
l'exclusion de de l'espace aérien de
tous les de tous les avions de tous les
avions libiens
euh pas de faire la guerre on nétait pas
supporté BB on nétait pas supposé
bombarder non alors c'est ça le vrai
problème la zone aérienne exclusive
euh c'est c'est c'est c'est déjà la
guerre ça c'est déjà mettre le doigt
dans l'engrenage parce que quand on y
est et qu'on voit les colonnes de char
se diriger bon ben la la tentation est
de de bombarder la tête de colonne bon
et personne ne voulait ça personne ne
voulait faire la guerre personne ne
voulait renverser le régime et la
plupart des gens savaient très bien que
si on renversait le régime on aurait les
on aurait le chaos et les
tribus et pourtant ça s'est passé
c'est-à-dire et l'engrenage a été plus
fort que la volonté des
acteurs c'est un cas d'école alors oui
c'est
le résultat est catastrophique mais
c'est c'est un cas d'école de nous
n'irons pas plus loin
queeux et et ensuite bah nous sommes
allés plus loin parce que parce que la
guerre est un engrenage parce que c'est
une montée aux extrêmes voilà parce que
quand vous êtes en face de chacun est
sur sur sur le terrain comme dans les
étatsmajors ça c'est lui ou moi la
guerre elle vous amène toujours à cette
extrémité toujours quand rou bon ombarde
il l ses bombes nucléaires et pourquoi
c'est c'est où nous c'est c'est où c'est
nos où c'est nos ce sont nos soldats qui
vont mourir où ce sont
eux la deuxième bombe nucléaire c'était
pas obligatoire si enfin était pas
obligatoire ils avaient pas cédé bah ils
étaient en grand chemin quand même non
ils avaient pas cédé japonais ils sont
résistants c'est voilà mais c'était et
de toute façon on était c'était dans
l'engennage puisqu'on y é voilà c'est
c'est à un moment donné c'est il on est
dans l'engronage on va en finir on va
finir par tous les moyens est-ce qu'on
analyse l'Ukraine là maintenant comment
est-ce qu'on analyserit l'Ukraine
maintenant al on va commencer à analyser
Ukraine à partir de quoi 2006 bah
l'Ukraine il faut non l'Ukraine ça ça
encore une fois c'est une c'est une
vieille histoire c'est que c'est 91
voilà en
91 les les on va on va encore une fois
très mal gérer la fin d'un d'un empire
ou l'effritement d'un empire euh au fond
les les les Occidentaux qui ont qui ont
versé une larme de crocodile quand
corbatchov est mort ont choisi non pas
de soutenir Gorbatchov mais de soutenir
yelsin et ils ont choisi pourquoi parce
que il au fond il y avait une espèce de
de
de de jouissance de de enfin de de
d'affaiblir le plus possible la Russie
voilà c'était euh donc plus ça allait se
décomposer mieux c'était avec tout en
essayant de faire en sorte que les
armements nucléaires ne partent pas dans
dans dans dans tous les sens mais on a
joué avec le feu sur
la et voilà ben donc on a tenu yelsin
yelsin lui son pouvoir il était assis
sur la Russie elle-même donc éit prêt à
ce que tout le reste euh s'en aille euh
on a livré la Russie par ras du gain
aussi euh aux oligarques euh il y aun
tas d'intérêts étrangers euh qui ont qui
ont mis le pays en coupe réglé par
arrivver tout seul poutine au pouvoir
est arrivé parce que et et il a assis
son son pouvoir et sa et sa et sa
popularité sur la mise au pas des
oligarques sur la ruine même des
oligarques qui étaient haï par la
population qui qui qui dans le passage
du communisme à la à la à la société de
de de marcher la plus débridée qui soit
la plus sauvage qui soit la plus
violente qui soit euh son
son bah sont venus à regretter l'autor
régime autoritaire
d'avir en plus que bon phénomène mafieux
et tout ce qu'il avait quand même oui
alors ça a été remplacé ça a été
remplacé par un
autre les oligarques au moment de la de
l'effondrement de du communisme ça a été
c'était d'une d'une indessence d'une
terrible et dans un moment o où les gens
souffraient beaucoup donc ils souffrait
et il voyait les autres s'enrichir et
s'emparer de toutes les richesses du
toutes les richesses du pays bon
donc là on
a on a géré aussi mal d'une certaine
façon qu'on avait géré la fin de la
première guerre mondiale que ça soit au
Moyen-Orient
ou en Europe
bien et puis après on a enfin l'Occident
ça ça
n'enlève ça rend pas Poutine plus
sympathique ni ça n'excuse rien du tout
mais mais ça refoir cette histoire nous
permet de penser que nous ne sommes pas
le camp du bien et que les guerres
n'arrivent pas simplement parce qu'il y
a quelqu'un qui décide de la guerre il
en général c'est tout le monde a sa part
de responsabilité et et là la la la
responsabilité a de de l'Occident dans
son ensemble a été de vouloir conduire
l'OTAN jusqu'aux frontières de la Russie
c'est tous les tous les spécialistes de
géopolitiqu
américains même ceux qui n'aimaient pas
la Russie qui l'avaient combattu détesté
de
euh ont écrit on dit
répéter que amener le l' temp aux
frontières de la de la Russie c'était
jouer avec le feu c'était prendre un
risque considérable et bien rien n'y a
fait rien n'y a fait
inexorablement voilà jus jusque
d'ailleurs au au au à l'accord de de
partenariat stratégique signé par les
États-Unis et l'Ukraine en en novembre
2021 quoi
c'est
on a empêché alors Markel Sarkozi ont
empêché en
2008 qu'on entame le processus d'entrée
de dans l'ut temp de la geéorgie et de
la et de l'Ukraine ce qu'on leur
reproche aujourd'hui mais s's étaient
rentrés dans l'UTAN voilà ilurait pas pu
attaquer l'Ukraine non on aurait sans
doute eu la guerre
plusutôt même le le l'actuel patron de
la CIA monsieur Burns qui était
ambassadeur en 2008 il est ambassadeur à
Moscou il est allé plusieurs fois il
était plusieurs fois en poste en Russie
ambassadeur des États-Unis à Moscou il
écrit une note à condolisaray qui est
secrétaire d'État de de George buouche
et il explique que si euh si l'Ukraine
rentre dans l'OTAN puisque la question
se posé à ce moment-là la Russie
prendrait des gages et notamment
notamment desgages en Crimée VO et que
c'est pas simplement la vie de Poutine
c'est que il a pendant 2 ans ou 2 ans et
demi il a vu tout le monde tout tout et
que en fait tout le monde en Russie sur
et sur cette ligne c'est prendre un
risque considérable cette note existe
elle a été publiée elle était
2008 il s'est passé exactement
c'est-à-dire que bon là ils sont pas
rentrés et puis en 2014 il y a eu la il
y a eu la révolution qui était pas une
révolution seulement spontanée bon
et
voilà vu l'influence de de de l'OTAN et
de l'Europe avancé ser avait très bien
dit il avait dit
euh la come brinski d'ailleurs enfin il
avait dit la la saz l'Ukraine c'est un
c'est un pont entre de monde et il faut
que ça le reste et donc la solution qui
été proposée par par y compris par
brinski on pouvait pas faire plus
antirusse que que
bzinski c'est c'est la seule solution
c'est la neutralisation c'estàdire queon
va laiss on va en faire un P entre les
deux et il faut neutraliser
neutralisation c'est c'est c'est pas
scandaleux c'est la neutralisation ça
sauveré la Finlande qui qui a continué
de vivre en état souverain même à
l'ombre de Staline voilà puisque la la
la guerre de fin sal n'a pas annexé la
Finlande à la fin de la guerre avec la
Finlande on a appelé ça la la
finlandisation mais ils ont ils ont vécu
libre pas du tout sous le régime
salinien ça a permis de de rétablir la
souveraineté de l'Autriche pendant la
guerre froide en 55 les tensions étaient
très très fortes et les les les deux
parties ont signé un un accord pour se
retirer chacun et neutraliser la
neutraliser l'Autriche euh ça a permis à
l'Autriche de de de retrouver sa
souveraineté d'éviter d'éviter une
guerre sur son territoire et voilà c'est
c'est pas je c'est pas une solution
aberérrante
c'était pourquoi ça s'est pas fait là ça
s'est pas fait parce que le le le le le
le parti
de parti de la guerre permanente é
toujours là quoi c'était fallait fallait
punir la R il fallait il fallait
emprisonner la Russie et la Russie c'est
c'est c'est comme B c'est comme
l'Allemagne quand elle se sonent
encerclé bah tout pays qui se sent
encerclé ou
menacé voilà il devient il devient hyle
alors je ne sais pas ce qu'aurait été
l'histoire on peut pas la
réécrire ça aurait peut-être pas
disuader
Poutine je je n'en sais rien en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que ce qu'on a fait
euh ne pouvait sans doute conduire qu'à
la situation que la situation actuelle
comment vous analysez toujours pareil
les hommes sont les hommes ils ont pas
changé voilà ouais mais oui mais c'est
c'est c'est c'est ça paraît une banalité
et c'est une banalité qu'on arrive pas à
intégrer dans la dans dans la politique
ni la géopolitique ni la politique
intérieure d'illeurs donc c'est ça là là
on voit quand même les vieilles ficelles
soit vous êtes avec nous soit vous êtes
contre nous soit vous êtes un colabou
soit vous êtes avec Pierre soit vous
êtes avec Paul on sent le clivage mais
quand on s'arrête un petit peu le boulot
de la France pour sentir le le la
tempête venir il a pas été fait ou il a
été pas
entendu parce que mais non il a pas été
fait enfin après ça dépend ce qu'on
comment on juge la vocation de la France
degol avait tracé une voix sur la dans
la France sur la scène
internationale cette voix c'était un la
fidélité aux alliances qu'on conclut
mais de la la la France ne veut pas être
entraînée dans une guerre don dont elle
n'accepte pas d'ê entrîn dans une guerre
dont elle ne voudrait pas donc elle
garde elle garde sa sa la maîtrce de son
de son destin et elle travaille elle
travaille à la à la elle travaille
trouver des solutions pacifiques chaque
fois que c'est que c'est
possible mais c'est c'est toujours
pareil derrière cette posture du du
général deg avec un principe très simple
la France reconnaît les les état pas les
régimes al aujourd'hui on vous parle que
des régimes c'est un régime c'est un
régime mauvais totalitaire autoritaire
euh
oui d'accord mais si on encore une fois
si si on si on est obsédé par cette
cette idée on va passer son temps à à
s'entretuer quoi je voilà donc l'idée de
de c'est ouais peut-être que Staline est
un est un même même sûrement hein que
c'est un c'est c'est sans doute un
criminel un des plus grands criminels de
l'histoire peut-être que Mao est un des
plus grands criminels de l'histoire mais
je reconnais l'Union soviétique parce
qu'elle est et làin en plus l'Union
soviétique a été la première à
reconnaître la France
libre je reconnais la Chine de Mao parce
que c'est parce que c'est une
réalité mais je c'est pas pour ça que je
reconnais le régime et puis vous savez
c'est quand même c'est c'est quand même
extraordinaire ça le méchant le très
bien est-ce'est-ce que Staline
était plus gentil
qu'itler non bon si on regarde au nombre
de et pourtant nos démocraties notre C
de de de la liberté
euh et même un anticommuniste aussi
viscéral que
Churchill sont se sont alliés sans état
d'âme sans État d'â à Staline contre
Hitler dilemme tragique voilà c'est ah
ben oui ben il y a Hitler et il y a
Staline bien et ben s'il faut s'allier à
Staline pour et bien on s'allie à Stal
on a fait pire on lui a donné la moitié
de
Europe souvenir
bon est-ce que Staline est-ce que
Poutine est pire que
Staline on pouvait discuter avec Staline
ça à Staline Staline mais mais mais mais
pas avec Poutine mais est-ce que il est
plus
dangereux plus criminel que que que
Staline est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression qu'il y a un autre jeu qui
en train de se jouer sous des prétextes
de les écoles pour les petites filles la
liberté la démocratie tout ce qui va
avec le packaging hollywoodien qui va
avec la guerre est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression qu'il y a une autre guerre
qui est en train de se jouer comme une
guerre de ressources d'accessibilité aux
ressources mais oui mais celle-là nous
sommes en train de sommes en train de la
perdre c'est-à-dire
que
oui c'est c'est tout le problème hein le
le le
le problème de cette guerre qui dure
c'est que elle elle est c'est c'est C
catastrophe pour l'Occident et en
particulier pour
l'Europe c'est donc quelle conclusion
vous tirez de ça parce que ça c'est à la
portée d'un gamin de 5 ans oui il faut
croire que la politique est
parfois imperméable à la pensée d'un
gamin de 5 ans en dessous la pensée d'un
gamin de 5 ans je c'est c'est on revient
toujours c'est toujours la même histoire
quoi c'est
euh d'abord l'Occident n'a pas compris
que enfin l'Occident en tout cas ses
dirigeants une partie de ses élites que
l'occidentalisation du monde c'était
fini 5 siècles c'est fini voilà c'est
fini il faut tourner cette page parce
que le monde le reste du monde l'a
tourné voilà donc non on est sorti de la
guerre froide et on a décidé que au lieu
d'accepter ce monde certes instable et
dangereux qui est le monde multipolaire
il fallait que de bipolaire il
deviennent unipolaire VO et nous allions
euh imposer au monde un ordre avec le
droit international Le Nôtre hein bon
qu'on respecte quand ça nous arrange euh
puce qu'on l' pas respecté au Kosovo on
na pas respecté en Afghanistan on l'a
pas respecté en irakon trs bien très
bien
euh
euh au lieu
de prendre en compte cette nouvelle
réalité du monde et essayer de
contribuer à à l'organiser on a préféré
la nier
alors j'entends bien oui c'est c'est
plus dangereux le monde multipolaire
mais c'est un fait c'est un fait et
l'Occident avec tous ses
moyens avec sa démographie n'est
absolument pas capable de d'imposer au
monde quand bien même il le voudrait son
ordre à lui c'est c'est ça n'est pas
possible on peut enfin voilà encore une
fois on va faire la guerre tout le temps
mais chaque fois qu'on l'a faite au nom
de cette idée ça s'est mal
terminé on se souvient bon pour parler
encore de l'Irak souvient de la les 20
ans d'occupation de l'Afghanistan se
sont se sont terminés par des images qui
sont qui sont abominables et on a oublié
cell de la chute de
Saigon parce que par toujours de c'est
toujours pareil munique munique munique
munichque mais il y a d'autres voies
pour aller dans vers des munies
terribles vers de terribles munique hein
c'est c'est c'est celle où la lassitude
des peuples les sacrifices trop grands
finissent parce qu'il faut bien en finir
un jour
euh par conduire par conduire l'Occident
à lâcher ses alliés sur place voilà et à
partir bon ben il est parti
d'Afghanistan il est parti du Vietnam
mais il faut se
souvenir souvenir de ce que ça enfin les
la chute de Saigon c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est terrible voilà on a et
et oui il a fallu il a fallu un peu de
sagesse à Nixon et à et à Kessinger pour
arrêter la la la la guerre du Vietnam ça
pouvait plus continuer mais le résultat
bah c'est une forme pour les gens qui
étaient là c'est une forme de munichque
l'Afghanistan pareil
enfin toutchoué quand les Américains ont
essayé de mettre de l'ordre en Somalie
ils ont dû partir avec un petit faucon
noir c'est ça ben oui c'est ça ENF ça
c'est un épisode mais très significatif
de ce de ce momentl enfin je je c'est
pareil on a semé le parce que l'Occident
n'y'est pas pour rien en tout cas une
partie de l'occi dans les printemps
arabes très bien on a on a vu ce qui
s'est passé en Égypte hein le pas parti
tout seul Mbarak bon ah bah on a eu les
Frères musulmans puis après bah c'est
c'est après dilemme tragique peut-être
il vaait mieux quand même le le régime
les milit l'armée égyptienne au pouvoir
que les Frères musulmans en Algérie on d
on pouvait détester le FLN et le le
pouvoir et le pouvoir algérien mais
quand il s'est agit de choisir entre
entre les islamistes et le et le pouvoir
en place dilème tragique vous bossz avec
SARC lors des des accords méditerranéens
signés à Nice ça vous rappelle quelque
chose à Nice àonti ou ça a été signé où
ça les accords méditerranéension pour la
Méditerranée ouis alors moi c'était une
idée que je poursuivais depuis très
longtemps
euh qu'on a
fini Sarkozi a a eu envie de mettre en
de mettre en œuvre
euh on les a signé à Paris il y avait
pas un petit passage à Nice non c'était
pas à Nice je sais plus c'est après il y
avait eu un conseil des ministre des
Affaires étrangères voilà est-ce que
dans l'idée j'essaie de vous
déconcentrer un petit peu est-ce que
dans l'idée il y avait pas un petit peu
les accords méditerranéens c'est pas un
peu les prémises à l'époque d'une garde
prétorienne européenne contre les flux
migratoires non mais ça aurait pu être
un moyen de les gérer
voilà l'idée de l'Union pour la
Méditerranée c'était c'était de changer
le rapport entre la rive nord et la rive
sud puisque jusque là c'était le c'était
le processus de Barcelone qui qui qui
gérait n nos rapports il y avit d'un
côté le bloc européen et puis de l'autre
les les pays du
Sud dont les Européens
imposai
imposai le leurs conditions aux autres
qui avaient pas leur Moot à dire c'était
espèce de néocol colonialisme déguisé il
faut appeler les choses par leur par
leur nom comme disaient les diplomates
du Sud bah la Commission européenne une
fois par an nous invite à prendre le thé
puis voilà
c'est ce qu'on a ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
essayé de faire c'était au début on
voulait unir les pays de la Méditerranée
entre eux puis les Européens on sont
découvert brusquement une les autres
pays européens un amour immodéré pour la
Méditerranée donc ils sont tous ven ils
sont venus à titre individuel voilà
c'estàd et on avait convenu que au moins
dans un premier temps ce serait les pays
de l'Europe du Sud qui qui qui prendrai
la coprésidence avec un pays de l'Europe
de de la rive sud et l'idée c'était de
faire un partenariat à part égal entre
entre les deux
euh ça ça ça a commencé ENF on a mis en
place ça c'était aussi alors tous les
Africains n'ont pas conçu n'ont pas reçu
comme ça mais c'est aussi une façon de
de créer une une une charnière entre le
continent africain et puis le
Moyen-Orient et
le et et les et les pays de l'Europe en
tout cas de l'Europe de l'Europe du
Sud tout ça c'est de façon étonnante mis
en place on a fini parc avec les
Allemands on a fait non sans mal mais on
a fini par par contre tous les pays de
la Méditerranée à à l'exception de de la
Libye kadfi disait ben puisquil y a tous
les pays européens je VO pas pourquoi il
y aurait pas tous les pays africains et
finalement euh c'est c'était pas plus
mal qu'il soit mais c'est le seul pays
méditerranéen qui n'était pas dans le
dans l'Union pour la Méditerranée et on
avait même réussi à me faire asseoir à
côté l'un de l'autre l'Autorité
palestinienne
et et l'État israélien le représentant
deétat Israël et tout ça s'est fracassé
sur la d'abord le fait que même en
France il y avait des gens qui qui n'y
croyaient pas qui ne jure que par
l'Europe voilà donc ça pouvait être que
l'Europe il fallait tout remettre à
l'Europe et puis par le fait ça s'est
fracassé aussi par de de deux
événements deux événements
majeurs d'abord des
des la résurgence de
problèm assez assez grave à l'époque
entre israéli israélien et palestinien
il y avait et puis euh les printemps
arabes et entre les deux la la crise la
crise financière qui a qui a qui a été
une des causes aussi des des printants
Arabes qui a mis voilà euh et par le
fait que les pays du Sud de la de
l'Europe n'avait à part la France
n'avait pas envie de prendre la
coprésidence l'Espagne était enfermée
dans ses dans la crise
financière sentait pas les reins solides
pour faire ça l'Italie était
indifférente à l'époque à cette idée
mais mais c'est c'est très dommage parce
que c'était une façon de gérer en commun
PIR gérer en commun et les flux
migratoires et et bien d'autres choses
la pollution de la Méditerranée le le
euh les la la la coopération économique
autour de autour de la Méditerranée il y
avait beaucoup de projets qui qui
étaient sur la table enfin on a raté une
occasion unique mais il faudra y revenir
parce que ce que l'Europe a du mal à
comprendre c'est que son avenir il se
joue au sud voà c'est c'est euh alors
peut-être qu'il se joue maintenant
aussi voilà du côté de la Baltique mais
mais
euh les sensé se joue au sud pour des
raisons d'abord parce que sa
civilisation vient du sud et puis parce
que la géographie fait que
euh voilà c'est c'est c'est en
Méditerranée que c'est toujours jou au
fond c'est toujours joué son réellement
son destin et ça revenons à l'Ukraine on
a eu euh Macron cléenceau pendant le
covid
ensuite on a eu Macron churchild Macron
Sunzu on a eu Stéphan ses journée
Gabriel Atal h
et on a Macron qui met des T-shirts et
des suits de l'armée Macron qui fait des
déclarations Tony truante Macron qui a
pas si longtemps il a 10 jours nous dit
que l'Ukraine c'est quand même pour des
questions économiques un petit peu vous
arrête moi je veux pas je veux pas
rentrercron cl ouais je pas rentrer dans
le débat politicien sur sur les uns et
les autes président la répme oui mais le
reste ça c'est pas le président la
République donc que chacun jugera si les
hommes sont à la hauteur de l'histoire
ou pas ce ce ce que je ce ce que je
trouve très dangereux c'est euh c'est
c'est cette cette cette idée
que la la la France n'aurait aucune
limite dans la le conflit ukrainien
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de la Russie que
nous serions prêts à envoyer des troupes
en Ukraine parce que envoyer des troupes
en Ukraine ça veut dire la guerre on t'a
dit que c'était des techniciens pour
déminer Henri tu as rien compris c'était
des techniciens pacifistes bah là c'est
pas très moi je suis pas pacifiste et je
suis pas belliciste les deux sont aussi
dangereux les uns que les autres les les
pacifistes parce qu'il pensent que
l'homme est bon et que voilà bah la
guerre très bien moi je je pense qu'il
faut tout faire toujours pour éviter la
pour éviter la guerre pour les raisons
qu'on a évoqué pendant pendant tout cet
entretien
euh parce que l'homme fond lui-même un
sauvage et cette la sauvagerie de la
guerre n'a pas de limite voilà mais je
je le belliciste vaut pas mieux parce
que le belliciste lui pense que la
guerre c'est régénérant voilà c'est
c'est plein de vertus de guerrière qui
vont régénérer l'homme ou qui vont
ressouder la société quand elle est
diviser c'est l'autre version du Bou
émissaire he c'est on va se on va on va
se trouver un ennemi commun ça va
resserrer les rangs voilà alors c'est
vrai que nos sociétés sont sont très
divisées mais je pense qu'elles sont
tellement divisées qu'elles vont elles
auront du mal à résister à à
un conflit de ce genre et euh mais
surtout tu on fait la guerre pour ses
intérêts vitaux la guerre encore une
fois hein c'est c'est lui ou c'est lui
ou moi c'est la guerre voilà c'est pas
la guerre c'est pas c'est c'est c'est
pas une expédition lointaine on envoie
quelques
parachutistees régler un problème de de
de
terroriste euh bon c'est pas ça hein
c'est c'est la guerre c'està-dire que là
euh si on envoie des soldats français
tirés sur des soldats russes et bien on
aura la guerre la
vraie est-ce que dans la contion
inam président de la République
disait nos intérêts fondamentaux ne sont
pas en jeu en
Ukraine voilà et maintenant c'est nos
intérêts fondamentaux son sont vitau
sont en jeu non nos intérêts vitaau ne
sont pas en jeu alors je peux me
tromper mais
C cette
idée il va pas s'arrêter il va mais il
va pas venir jusqu'à Paris ni même
jusqu'à Berlin est-ce que vous comprend
Macron comme disait un diplomate il y a
pas longtemps de toute façon nous avons
nous sommes non seulement en face de de
de puissance puissance militaire
importante mais nous sommes en face
d'une puissance nucléaire voilà qui
dispose de 5000 au moins 5000 ou 6000
têtes nucléaire alors de deux choses
l'une ou bien le ou bien l'Union la
Russie s'effondre je je rappelez-vous de
l'angoiss qui a saisi les chancelleries
occidentales quand les troupes de
Prigogine étaient sur la route de
Moscou hein c'est
c'est après après Poutine qui voilà et
d'autre part si la
Russie s'effondre alors Poutine il a il
a on peut dire que c'est un monstre
froid c'est pas un exalté hein vous avz
remarqué
c'est il a pas il a manifestement pas
envie de de de d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire pas plus pas plus que nous
mais faut faire attention encore une
fois à l'engonnage c'est pas la même
doctrine l'angonnage on peut ne pas
avoir envie et finir par le faire quand
même mais si la Russie s'effondre c'est
une catastrophe planétaire c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est tout le
continent asiatique qui va être
déstabilisé c'est des milliers de têes
nucléaire qui don on sait pas où elles
vont partir enfin je je je dire c'est
c'est c'est un chaos terrible don la la
première victime encore une fois c'est
là aussi là aussi l'Europe donc et et on
ne peut
pas ça c'est l'hypothèse où ça
s'effondre de de l'intérieur mais on
peut pas vaincre la Russie ne peut pas
perdre c'est pas un souhait hein elle
peut pas perdre parce que parce que
c'est infé bah c'est une puissance vous
pouvez pas faire ce que vous la russi ce
que vous avez fait avec l'Allemagne en
1945 voilà parce qu'il y a 6000 tê
nucléire parce que c'est une puissance
nucléaire donc non mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est essentiel et donc elle ne
peut cette guerre ne peut s'arrêter que
par la négociation voilà il faudra bien
à un moment ou un autre si c'est un
match à mort si c'est ça peut pas être
un match à mort c'est mat c'est un match
à mort pour les ressources mais ça peut
pas être à mort parce que si c'est à
mort ça ça veut dire des dizaines de
millions de morts bah oui bah non il y a
aucune ressource qui qui vaut ça ça
c'est quoi on va sacrifier la moitié de
l'humanité dans une guerre mondiale à
coup de missile nucléaire pour mais il y
a il y a rien qui vaut ça rien ça ça
fait penser à un mauvais film quand même
non hein ça fait penser à un mauvais
film je pas je ça fait penser à un
mauvais film
euh ça devient un mauvais film ou un
caemar oui mais parce que c'est regardez
c'est moi pendant 2 ans après avoir
écrit une tribune en 2000 2022 pour
expliquer que on marchait vers l'arrière
comme desces en buulle
et alerter sur l'engrenage et la montée
aux extrêmes dans la guerre m'a dit mais
regardez il y a il y a pas d'engrenage
il y a pas de il y a pas d'escalade
voilà chaque fois qu'on franchit une
soisant ligne rouge il se passe rien
donc on peut continuer ça c'est le
moment où ça devient le plus dangereux
parce que le vous ne savez que c'était
la dernière ligne rouge
qu'après voilà si vous savez pas avant
vous savez qu'après donc et plus on
passe on croit passer de ligne rougege
sans sans problème et plus on est tenté
d'en passer d'autres
voilà c'est c'est c'est une addiction
c'est une fr
et là l'escalade elle est là elle est là
dans dans le désarmement elle est là
dans le fait que petit à petit la Russie
est touchée aussi sur son sur son sur
son territoire et que je suis pas sûr
que ça affaiblisse le pouvoir en
place ça peut aussi souder la population
russe autour du du pouvoir en place mais
en tout cas l'escalade l'escalade dans
l'armement elle monte l'escalade dans
les mots elle monte mais l'escalade dans
les mot c'est pas neutre c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas anecdotique jeescalade des
mots elle finit par par provoquer
l'escalade des pensées des idées c'est
vous déjà pris la tête avec un russe
avec un Russe
non pouro même pas une petite bagarre de
barre non
jamais qu'est-ce que vous connaissez des
Russes
l'histoire vous avez été en Russie oui
j'étais en Russie ou combien de fois où
une fois à Moscou combien de temps pas
très longtemps assez pour voir
Poutine avec qui avec Sarkozi vous avez
lu quoi de la Russie quel auteur quel
poète quel musicien ce que tout le monde
a lu Tolstoy
dostoyevski mais ça c'est intéressant
aussi parce que cette idée cette idée
qu'il faut être all la plupart des gens
qui vont sur place ne voi rien surtout
les journalistes non mais les
journalistes comme les autres c ils
vivent vous allez à Moscou vous vivez
dans un dans le quoi le monde des
startup ou
des vous vivez dans un dans un monde qui
n'a rien à voir avec tout le reste de la
Russie chacun vit dans son dans son
petit monde on ne connaît pas forcément
un pays il faut y vivre vraiment pendant
des des années des années des années des
décennies pour pour vraiment s'imprégner
donc donc je sais pas si vous êtes allé
en ri mais au fond vous en savez pas
plus que moi euh c'est pas sûr non mais
parce que on la la la la politique ça ça
ça s'apprend enfin ce que ce que pensent
les autres ça s'apprend aussi en
réfléchissant en lisant le leur
littérature en regardant leur histoire
de Gool n'avait pas fait tous les pays
de la terre et pourtant il les
connaissait beaucoup mieux que la
plupart des gens qui avaient fait qui
avaient passé leur temps en globe
trotteur autour du monde TR est très
bien pour con P c'est son art culinaire
voilà mais vous savez pourquoi toujours
important l'art culinaire mais mais
pourquoi mais l'AR culinaire il est pas
le même à Vladivostock et à Moscou ouis
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
en terme d'épic et de cuisson mais la
majeure partie du temps que vous avez un
pays avec un art culinaire très
rustre ça
se traduit aussi dans leur caractère
mais il y a pas besoin il y a même pas
besoin de passer passer par là le je
dire le caractère des des Russes on on
le connaît parce que leur histoire est
une histoire extraordinairement violente
euh c'est voilà c'est c'est fait le le
la Russie en tout cas la Russie
occidentale c'est produit un croisement
entre les Vikings et les et et les
Slaves qui étaient c'était des roues
place c'est ça c'était des roues c'était
des roues après ce mélange entre Slav
les Slaves qui étaient là enfin tribus
Slav qui étaent là et puis les les
Vikings qui ont fondé Kiev et qui qui
avait qui exploitait la ligne Le fleuve
le NIP comme quel regard quel regard
vous portez sur
nos mais ce censé conseiller n nos
dirigeants nos stratèges quel regard
vous portez sur
eux quel regard vous portez sur les
experts de plateau
télé bah comme il m'arrive d'aller sur
les plateaux télé je on va éviter de
leur cracher dessus c'est ça non c'est
ou c'est pas ça enfin je veux dire ce
qu'on voit de temps en temps des gens
intelligents lucides quelle que soit
leur opinion mais et puis de temps en
temps des des des spectacle qui est et
qui est affligeant mais là encore c'est
c'est c'est une his de nature humaine
c'est c'est comme pendant la la pandémie
brusquement des gens se
trouvent se trouvent investi dans
pouvoir ou d'une autorité que les
circonstances le leur accordent donc
pendant la pandémie c'était les
professeurs de médecine même ceux qui
avaient jamais fait d'épidémiologie de
leur vie euh et puis là bah c'est les
généraux voilà ils sont au centre on
regarde queeux on leur demande leur leur
avis a une forme de pouvoir qui se
euh voilà mais vous pourriez me dire
mais
euh vous avez pas passé 10 ans dans
l'armée donc vous pouvez pas juger bah
si heureusement d'ailleurs
c'est
euh vous défendez Macron là non je
défends pas Macron je vous dis
simplement que c'est c'est pas parce
qu'on n'est pas militaire de carrière
qu'on peut peut pas avoir une idée enfin
sur la jeends l'empleendexemple suivant
je prends l'exemple suivant un
soviéologue un
néooviétologue qui va à Moscou que dans
son petit trip d'expatrie dans son
truc petit truc d'expatrié où il y a
tout
tous les mê réseau as de suite bon le
militaire qui était à l'ut temp avec son
prisme de lecture de l'UTAN pas de
problème le S tank en question pas de
problème le service de renseignement
tout le monde vit dans son dans son
petit milieu
socioculturel et puis et puis il y a les
clientèles aussi il y a beaucoup de
clientèle oui c'est un business oui et
nous nous on regarde depuis notre balcon
dans l'ombre ce qui se raconte on va un
peu sur le terrain je depuis 2014 oui on
écoute les journalistes à gauche à
droite du Centre on voit les fumistes
oui mais et ensuite nous en tant que
citoyen français
informé quel va être notre
[Musique]
rôle d'abord les les les gens ont le
rôle qui dans le débat public qui
s'autorise à avoir enfin je
euh vous savez si le si le si le pays
veut la guerre il y aura la guerre si le
pays la veut pas il y aura pas la guerre
voilà c'est c'est ça veut dire quoi le
pays ah ben quand je vois que Macron il
gouverne le pays avec 22 % de fr non il
ti pas le pays il tient ça ça inelligen
parisienne d' non parce que chose se
passe pas comme ça les les vous auriez
pu vouloir la guerre en 1938 vous
l'auriez pas eu parce parce parce que en
France laécrasante majorité des gens ne
la voulaient pas voilà et on a fait la
guerre que que quand les Allemands sont
venus en France c'est que nous nous on
attend que Poutine bute des soldats
Françis en Ukraine pour qu'on y aille
franchement non le problème là qui c'est
le le danger et que et que les
dirigeants nous entraînent dans cet
engrenage mais vous avez Vuon comme
dirigeant h vous avez vu les dirigeants
qu'on a Olaf Scholz qui B les Anglais et
les français pour se racheter une
virginité
bah faut faut faut le comprendre on a on
a censé euh le modèle allemand pas
seulement économique c'est qui o mais
bah lisz les journaux les les
observateurs les médias les politiques
éta tout le monde tout le monde trouvait
ça très bien puis même le citoyen AR
l'Allemagne c'était parfait c'était
beaucoup mieux que que ce qu'on faisait
en France donc et la démocratie
allemande en particulier vous vous
rendez compte c'est tellement bien le le
système proportionnel les pays où on
fait des on arrive à faire des
coalitions après les élections hein
c'est fantastique c'est c'est et quand
on quand on disait mais c'est quand même
le contraire de la démocratie
c'està-dire c'est je fais pas des
coalition avant les élections fait des
coalitions après donc on constate qu'il
y a pas de majorité bon ben c'est très
bien alors on va faire on va faire une
coalition on va reécrire en programme
pour quelle personne n'a
voté bah oui c'est ça c'est ça le
système allemand qui c'est ça les
arguments que que vous jettes à la
figure tous les partisans de la de la
proportionnelle
bon très bien alors bah de temps en
temps il y a les les on est dansfin on
est dans des
périodes c'est pas très grave au fond ou
bien les gouvernants ont assez de sont
assez vertébrés pour pour arriver à en
faire quand même quelque chose qui qui
tient de vous et et puis puis y a des
périodes où ça ça ça ne ça peut pas
marcher voilà bah là l'Allemagne est en
train d'explorer les limites extrêmes de
son de son système vous avez une
coalition qui est qui a qui a qui à
l'épreuve enfin face à une épreuve qui
est pas une épreuve ordinaire ah bah
elle a du mal à tenir la tenir la route
vois parce que là ça fait apparaître des
des fractures à l'intérieur même de la
coalition majoritaire terrible et puis
et puis les gens sont pas bah voilà
Monsieur sch c'est pas Madame Merkel bon
c'est pas non plus voà c'est c'est c'est
pas den noer c'est pas c'est pas
bilibrante c'est pas bah
ouais ben nous c'est pareil c'est pas de
Goul c'est pas
Pompidou B voilà il faut faire avec bah
on est obligé de faire avec jus jusqu'à
un certain point moi ma philosophie
politique et ma philosophie tout court
c'est que c'est c'est c'est qu'il faut
il faut il faut faut
jamais se départir de l'idée de
limite c'est faut mettre t limites aux
politique non il faut re des limites
c'est-à-dire nous en tant que peuple
tous en tant que peuple en tant
qu'individu c'est-à-dire que il y a il y
a rien de pire que les absolus voà donc
déjà quand on me dit il y a pas de
limite dans la dans dans le conflit avec
avec la Russie c'est c'est c'est déjà
une folie quoi voilà tout a des limites
mais c'est une folie de crocodile c'est
une folie de crocodile Macron c'est un
crocodile je sais pas si c'est un
crocodile mais vous connaissez
l'expression a une grande gueule et tout
petits bras
oui mais ça ça le problème c'est que
c'est que dans ce genre
d'engrenage c'est pas ces bras qui vont
qui vont qui vont agir sont les ntres
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ces
CASL on nal qui en
premier encore une fois dans ces cas-là
moi je pour l'instant on n est pas on
n'est pas tout à fait au bord de la de
la guerre mais après bah on fait ce
qu'on fait dans une démocratie on
manifeste bah oui mais qu une fois si si
vraiment les gens veulent pas il
manifesteront qu'il veulent pas
je voilà mais le Dr le risque est que
même en ne voulant pas la polarisation
les graines de polarisation elles sont
jetées vous vous en avez subi
quelquesunes soit vous êtes avec nous
soit vous êtes contre n soit vous êtes
Cabo soit vous êtes colabo donc là on
les voit les vieilles ficelles débarquer
on voit l'organigramme le spectre de
sing tank d'experts à gauche à droite
polarisé c'est oui mais c'est pas que
les sing tank c'est c'est euh c'est la
plupart des partis politiques ne ne ne
disent rien sur la sur la guerre pas
plus qu'ils n'ont dit quoi que ce soit
sur la façon on a géré la pandémie c'est
on prend pas de risque ou alors on dit
je suis contre mais je vote pour euh de
de peur d'être accusé d'être collabau
d'être Vich d'être d'être municois
d'être lâche d'être c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est extraordinaire mais c'est
comme ça vous savez on n'arrive pas dans
une situation comme celle dans laquelle
nous sommes par hasard d'abord les
peuples ont la aussi la politique qui
mérite impression que consacré c'est les
périodes douces font des hommes faibles
et les périodes dures font des hommes
forts c'est ça oui enfin ça fait émerger
ça peut faire émerger des caractères he
c'est il pas d'homme
providentiel mais ça ça on ne le sait
qu'après he vous vous présentez aux
prochaines élections sa qu'après mais
moi je suis pas je pas de réponse là
mais non parce que je suis pas fou enfin
je veux dire c'est non mais fou ça veut
dire je je vais sortir dans la rue je
vais dire ah ben je suis candidat
élection présidentielle faites pas ça
tout seul là encore c'est c'est vous
vous vous pouvez faire ça si s'il y a un
courant qui vous porte s'il y a une une
une envie des gens vous savez en
1957 personne n'ait envie de voir le
général de Goul revenir revenir au
pouvoir les sondages ils sont
terrifiants c'est c'est 14 % 12
% personne et ses propres amis ne
pensaient pas qu'il reviendrai et puis
en 58 il y a le 13 mai et puis les les
les les euh par ont peur d'être jeté à
la la scène dans la scène par les
parachutistes et puis
brusquement c'est c'est très intéressant
de lire les journaux de qui précède
cette période de 1 an 2 ans c'est là il
se passe rien enfin je veux dire on est
là il y a les cantonnal on s'occupe des
cantonnales de des petits sous-bressau
de de de l'économie ou de la
Bourse voilà et puis et puis brusquement
d'un seul coup d'un seul coup le gouffre
apparî ouvert devant ah bah là il vont
se coup le goufre il le découvre oui
mais il découvre devant devant leur pied
donc à ce moment-là à ce moment-là il
cherche et puis ben il y a la seule
solution c'est le le monsieur à Colombé
et ils vont le ils vont le chercher et
lui il leur dit mais je reviens si on
change la Constitution ah bah il étaient
pas prêt à la changer mais là il voilà
sont prê à changer c'est c'est l'homme
l'homme providentiel c'est il épouse les
circonstances c'est vous vous ne savez
pas avant et vous savez pas d'ailleurs
si si si est providentiel ou si il est
diabolique hein c'est la philosophie de
Dune ça c'est est-ce que
euh si si vous regardez bien on a sur
200 ans on a jamais résolu une crise
politique grave par les par Lesur jamais
jamais c'est c'est c'est voà depuis 18
brumè jusqu'au 13 mai jamais résolu 13
mai c'est alors on peut se dire c'est
des goolises qui ont monter un complot
d'accord mais mais juste le système
politique il était totalement bloqué sur
la 4e la fin de la 4e République c'est
au centre vous avez ça ressemble un peu
à ce qu'on a aujourd'hui euh au centre
vous aviez les partis de gouvernement
qui se qui se partageit le pouvoir ça
allait du du CNI de Pinet à droite à la
SFIO de de guimolé à gauche
bon démocrates chrétiens les radicaux et
ils se partagent le pouvoir on changé de
gouvernement tous les 6 mois euh mais il
y avait et puis il y avait la majorité
du des gens étaient ailleurs mais elle
pouvait pas constituer une majorité de
gouvernement il les communistes d' un
côté les Gaulistes de de l'autre et bon
pouvait pas donc donc le système était
bloqué en plus il était verrouillé par
ce qu'on appelle le système des
apparentement donc voilà il y avait pas
de solution dans les urnes alors ça
aurait pu être autre chose que le 13 mai
mais en tout cas ça pouvait pas finir
par les autres puisque c'était le
système était bloqué or il était bloqué
en plus pas dans une période comme les
mais il était il était
bloqué face à une crise financière qui
devenait inquiétante puisque que la
France allait frapper à la porte du FMI
pouraider et à la crise algérienne qui
prenait un caractère al tout à fait
dramatique voilà donc et et le ce ce
pouvoir ne pouvait pas résoudre C ces
ces ces problèmes bon voilà à ce
moment-là mais mais dans ces moments-là
vous pouvez avoir le meilleur ou le pire
c'est-à-dire que si vous avez de la
chance et la France a eu plutôt de la
chance eu Napoléon 1er Napoléon 3 de
Goul on peut ne pas aimer les uns et les
autres enfin voilà les autres ont eu bah
ils ont eu Hitler Staline
mussoliniin c'est c'est est-ce qu'on
aura toujours de la chance je n'en sais
rien ce que je je mais je ce que je sais
c'est que la pente que nous prenons est
une pente extrêmement dangereuse euh et
que la la le sursaut il peut venir que
du très fond du du du du pays si si si
personne n'est assez lucide euh
pour prendre conscience de la du gouffre
qui s'ouvre devant nous du gouffre de
violence qui s'ouvre devant nous c'est
gardez cette cette société tout le monde
a ses bouc émissaires c'est tout le
monde est le bouc émissaire de quelqu'un
le le la violence physique à l'intérieur
de la société elle monte comme une marée
qu'on arrive plus à arrêter
euh des fractures s'ouvrent c'est pas
propre d'ailleurs à la France c'est
propre à tous les pays d'occidentaux
regardez l'image des regardez les
États-Unis regardez ces pays coupés en
deux bon regardez Israël juste avant
avant les les les attentats pays coupé
en deux GZ les pays qui sont dans
l'orbite de l'Occident comme comme le
Brésil
ou c'est même Bolson Bolson faire
pratiquement la moitié des en dans des
des voies dans un pays radicalement
coupé en deux
euh regardez l'état de l'Allemagne de de
l'Allemagne est la la société la plus
dual d'Europe
euh ils sont il sont ils ont pas réussi
à intégrer le à intégrer l'Allemagne de
l'Est vous avez une partie de la société
qui est dans les les grandes entreprises
ou les les les grandes PME euh on
emploie quasiment à vie la cogestion les
syndicats bon puis vous avez tout le
reste
tout le reste et et et ce ce modèle
tenait parce que l'énergie pas chè parce
que les les les marchés marchés
asiatiques parce que l'euro non pour
l'Allemagne c'était pas parce que l'euro
l'Allemagne pas profité mais mais voilà
et puis tout tous toutes ces tous ces
toutes ces ces ces poutres de de
soutenement sont pour ement son s fondre
vous retrouvez la la la la société
allemande livrée elle-même dans l'état
où est c'est-à-dire fracturé dans dans
tous les sens tous les pays occidentaux
sont sont dans cette situation tous les
pays occidentaux payent le prix de la
mondialisation heureuse ce qu'on a fait
sans aucune précaution voilà c'est même
les États-Unis qui ont pris un peu de
précaution qui sont plus
protectionnistes que les autres
il c'est quoi les petits blancs qui
votent pour pour pour Trump sinon les
victimes de la mondialisation sodisant
heureuse voilà vous rajoutez à ça
l'Europe qui a qui a qui a qui a
faummenté une une crise de des
démocratie européenne qui qui est qui
est qui est terrible puisque on a on a
on a retiré avec le leur consentement le
le le pouvoir du le pouvoir au politique
nationaux alors qu'il y a on peut pas
avoir une démocratie européenne puisque
pour avoir une démocratie il faut un
peuple et qu' y a des peuples européens
et non pas un peuple européen euh donc
là on s'en é tiré en dépolitisant
l'économie et la société voilà le
problème c'est que quand vous êtes en
face d'une d'une crise le problème c'est
que quand les gens souffrent leur seule
instance d'appel c'est la politique
c'est-à-dire la l'irruption de la
volonté dans l'histoire de de la volonté
collective bon là vous pouvez vous
tourner les gens vers le politique le
politique qui soit bon ou qui soit
mauvais qui soit à la hauteur ou pas à
la hauteur B la veille de l'élection il
vous dit vous allez voir tout changé et
le lendemain il vous dit j'y peux rien
c'est pas moi bon et vous ça ça conduit
où ça conduit où
sinon sinon dans un premier temps au
chaos à la
violence et puis après dans un besoin
d'ordre d'autorité de pouvoir très fort
et là ben après avoir passé le chos et
la violence vous aurez soit l'homme
providentiel de Goul soit soit l'homme
providentiel mais funeste voilà c'est
pas c'est c'est tout encore une fois
tout ça c'est la nature humaine dont on
s'est moqué on s'est qu'on a qu'on a
négligé pendant des décennies en pensant
qu'on était tellement meilleur que tous
ceux qui nous ont précédé tellement plus
intelligents que que tellement différent
on c'est comme si on avait subi une
révolution anthropologique
extraordinaire qui avait fait de nous
des enfin de
nous de nous tous des êtres des êtres
qui n'avaient plus rien à apprendre
transcendantal voilà mon intelligence
c'est un
obstacle je claque 700 milliards en 7
ans h je claque 9 milliards par
mois je
suis je suis je suis je sais pas Bruno
le mer hein vous connaissez pas ce
fameux jeu ah non vous connaissez pas ce
jeu mais moi ça ça ça me fait pas rire
quoi voilà je c'est pas c'est mais c'est
pas seulement c'est pas seulement brun
mer c'est c'est ENF c'est c'est c'est
c'est tout c'est tout un système ce que
degal appelit le système hein c'est euh
voilà système de pensée système euh de
de de de système politique système
économique enfin ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a fait délirant on a tenu on a
tenu en tout en tout que ça soit dans la
politique international dans le euh dans
dans dans la politique intérieure en en
tout dans l'économie dans la dans la
dans la société c'est euh est-ce qu'on
peut appeler un chat un chat 2 secondes
benah ça dépend ça dépend bah i ça
dépend que qui qui est le
CH qui est la
souris on se retrouve face à un système
économique qui à bout de souffle qui ne
tient que par des dettes qui ne sont
Baqué sur aucune ressource énergétique
fiable vous êtes pas c'est quoi ce ha de
sourcil non je trouve c'est un peu trop
simple voilà c'est un peu trop simple je
vous autorise à mettre un peu plus de
complexité non je je je je j'essaie de
résumer à la hauteur du politique hein
oui mais cherchez pas parce que résumer
le vide c'est la politique c'est le vide
bah c'est devenu le vide
oui comment on fait pour gérer vide
regardez c'est
c'est moi je suis c'est tout est
délirant non mais tout est délirant
c'est c'est c'est un défi à
l'intelligence humaine c'est alors on
vous
dit on a euh on a une dette qui fait euh
3000 milliards non 110 % un peu plus de
110 % du PIB ça vous ça ça ça ça ça ça
vous viendrait à l'idée de ramener votre
votre dette à votre revenu
annuel nous on aime bien ça vous viendra
l'idée non mais c'est l'espace de 5
minutes hein l'espace de 5 minutes de
prendre conscience un éclair de lucidité
mais non c'est pas un éc cité vous
ramenez jamais votre dette que ça soit
celle de votre entreprise ou la vôtre
vous la ramenez jamais à votre revenu
annu annuel ce que vous ramenez à votre
revenu annuel c'est le service de la
dette mais c'est pas la dette la dette
c'est un stock voilà c'est quand vous
achetez un appartement vous regardez pas
votre taux d'endettement en fonction de
votre r annuel on garde les taux
d'intérêt ben vous regardez ce que vous
avez à payer chaque année et puis tout
ça vous le rapportez c'estàdire un flux
à un flux bon voilà c'est c'est
élémentaire c'est pas donc les taux
augmentent tout le monde se retrouve à
poil non les Tau augmentent là aussi ça
il faut faudrait des heures pour
discuter de ça c'est pas mais les est-ce
que les toréel
augmentent très
peu quoi ça fait on est à combien 25
c'est ça les tour réels ils sont à
combien ah bah ça dépend des échéances
he maisord à 20 ans mais voilà on on n
pas loin de on n'est pas loin de 3 %
pour des échances à 10 ansbond américain
il a combien là le tibond américain il
est combien je sais pas je regardé le la
France mais pas les États-Unis mais de
tel faible enfinel on peut augmenter et
ça vous arrive de de convertir votre
dette en consommation journalière en en
baril de pétrrole mais je vois je enfin
moi je vois pas l'intérêt de faire ce
genre de ce genre de ce genre de calcul
si des fois c'est marrant oui c'est
marrant mais c'est voilà c'est ça ça
n'apporte rien ça n'apporte rien je
reviens je reviens au tau d'intérêt
quand on me dit non non je reviens taux
d'intérêt quand on quand on me dit ça ça
dites les taux d'intérêt ça salouri r
mais euh si les taux d'intérêt réels
augmentent pas ou peu
euh où est le problème le problème il
est pas dans l' il est pas dans les dans
les taux d'intérêts nominaux il est il
est le problème il est dans la manière
dont nous avons réagi à
l'inflation parce que ben oui c'est
c'est voulez faire augmenter les
recettes de l'État et et rendre le la
rendre l'inflation
neutre bah à ce momentlà indexer les
salaires ah non c'est dangereux ça ah
bon hein c'est PASC il pas dit dere on
on va pas ouvrir ce débat mais mais en
quoi c'est en quoi c'est dangereux en
quoi c'est dangereux la Belgique qui a
une indexation bien plus poussée que la
nôtre nous c'est interdit d'indexer
elle a elle a elle a réduit son
inflation moins vite que nous là et en
1900 au début des années 80 elle a
réduit moins vite que nous non elle a
fait elle a réduit plus vite que nous
c'est c'est extraordinaire c'est c'est
on peut pas discuter de ça non plus on
peut discuter de rien en fait c'est
c'est on a on a décidé qu'on avait
réussi à vaincre l'inflation au début
des années 80 par la désindexation des
salaires mais la plupart des pays n'ont
pas n'ont pas utilisé cette cette
technique et ils ont réduit leur
inflation aussi et parfois plus vite que
nous nous on a fait on a fait porter
tout l'ajustement sur les sur sur sur
les salaires et on on le paye encore ça
va durer combien de temps les les les le
pouvoir d'achat des salaires alors
politiques ils ont ren autre à dire que
alors soit soit soit ils disent rien sur
le sujet soit ils vous disent faut que
le travail paye pour que le travail paye
il faut bah il faut baisser les
allocation hein voilà très bien bon mais
le pouvoir d'achat des salaires tout le
monde s'en fiche hein euh sauf sauf sauf
les salariés voilà sauf les salariés
donc ils étaient déjà étranglés avant
avant l'inflation euh ben maintenant ils
sont encore plus étranglés ça va durer
combien de temps combien de temps une
société peut tenir avec une une société
soit-disant fondée sur la valeur travail
sur et ca sur leseff combien de temps
elle elle peut tenir avec cette ce
retard insensé des des du du pouvoir
d'achat des salaires combien de temps je
pense que la la la question est mal
formulée c'est combien de temps la
classe politique va pouvoir continuer à
parader sans se faire suivre à la trace
oui mais c'est c'est c'est pareil c'est
c'est un banquier qui était venu un
banquier est venu voir le président de
la République en 2008 un grand banquier
américain une très grande manque
d'affaires américaine et puis il a
raconté l'histoire suivante il a dit un
matin je suis sorti de chez moi il y
avait 200 personnes qui faisaient le
tour de la maison avec des panneaux
voleur rend l'argent ah dit ça fait un
drôle d'fet mais la prochaine fois ils
rentront peut-être dans la maison voilà
politique banquier tout ce que vous
voudrez c'est qu'il y a un moment donné
c'est ça aussi c'est l'impensée totale
de de la situation actuelle c'est alors
on voit bien la crise culturelle bien on
voit bien la crise VO bien la guerre
parce que est porte donc quand même par
se rendre compte et
encore qu'on a j'ai l'impression qu'on a
encore à apprendre sur ce qui'est la
guerre quoi euh et puis on voit bien la
délinquance trafic de drogue mais alors
la la la la la la crise
sociale qui est une qui est une bombe
sociale c'est c'est alors là c'est c'est
c'est ça c'est totalement occulté quoi
c'est et peut-être pas tant que ça parce
que ils ont lâché du pognon à gogo mais
non ils ont lâché du pognon à gogo à qui
on a fait enfin mais on va pas mais mais
regardez là on a fait on a fait un
bouclier énergétique mais c'est absurde
parce que tous les milliards qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a
dépensé soupoudré sur sur un tas de gens
ça ne représente rien en revanche la
facture d'électricité ça ça représentait
beaucoup on aurait mieux fait de sortir
du marché unique de l'électricité
ah ben oui voilà et on aurait payé notre
électricité au coup de production mais
non on a on a raconté n'importe quoi au
j en expliquant que si on faisait ça on
pourrait plus impemporter du de
d'électricité quand on en aurait besoin
mais c'est c'est une plaisanterie mais
personne a dit que c'était une
plaisanterie c'était peut-être un
braquage non c'est espèce de non c'est
il y a plus personne naccepte de
réfléchir c'est la politique des
marqueurs c'est sociale la guerre
sociale qui arrive là vous la sentez
comment la S mal genre un peu
moyenageuse plutôt mais moi je je sais
je ne sais pas quelle quelle tête elle
aura comme je ne sais pas quelle tête
aura le le besoin d'ordre est perdu
après le chaos et la violence
bon ce que je sais c'est que dans
l'histoire les crises sociales sont
souvent les plus violentes voilà c'est
c'est
euh ça peut pas continuer comme ça voilà
c'est c'est et continuer comme ça mais
ça peut pas ça peut
pas continue à ne pas regarder les
choses en face là c'est très bien on dit
voilà on a 5 et dem % de de déficite bon
très bien on a 3000 milliards de dettes
bon à 1000 milliards on était en
faillite à 2000 on était en faillite à
3000 on est en faillite bon très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va on va
diminuer le nombre de de fonctionnaires
alors va diminuer le nombre de
profs va diminuer le nombre de policiers
d'infirmière d'infirmière de médecins
d'hospitalier de de quoi c'estàd tous
ces métiers dont nous avons absolument
besoin où on trouve plus de
candidats qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on
hypothèque la génération future
française c'est pas qu'on hyp on
hypothèque le présent déjà oui l'avenir
mais c'est on peut pas s'en passer enfin
je c'est un problème vous appelez le
plan appeler le serrurier à à 10h du
soir parce que vous avez oublié votre
clé à l'intérieur euh 250 € les 10
minutes euh pour ouvrir la porte bah
vous payez parce que va faire autrement
donc là on se trouve coincé entre une
euh la la gestion de nos finances
publiques passées et euh et les besoins
c'est les retards qu'on a qu'on a pris
euh dans le dans dans la rémunération du
du travail voilà c'est c'est euh après
vous vous pouvez toujours considérer que
les gens sont telle ou telle catégorie
est trop payé seulement si cette
catégorie vous en avez vraiment besoin
et qu'elle elle estime qu'elle est pas
assez payer et que que les gens ne sont
plus candidats et ne viennent plus bien
vous avez un problème ça s'appelle la
loi de l'offre et de la demande et c'est
vrai même pour les fonctionnaires même
pour les conducteurs de train même pour
les infirmières qui vont en Suisse même
bah oui même pour les infirmières les
médecins hospitaliers les policiers les
magistrats voilà donc c'est c'est
c'est ne pas regarder en face c'esté un
pas se contenter de de de de de phrases
vided de sens pendant des années on vous
explique que le rabot c'est pas une
bonne idée c'est vraiment c'est
politique la plus stupide qu'il soit
puis dès qu'on est au pied du mur on dit
bah on va faire le rabot voilà c'est
c'est sauf qu' il y a plus rien à
raboter quoi je euh
enfin vous savez c'est c'est
c'est qu'est-ce qui va se passer tout
pas enfin encore une fois euh c'est on
on est dans une dans une impass totale
vous vous et il y
acune possibilité d'aborder réellement
ces sujets de réfléchir de de non c'est
on s'entire avec des slogans avec des
mots alors en politique internationale
c'est c'est munique dans le reste c'est
ah bah les assister cancer de
l'assistance quand on aura résolu ça
tout va aller euh alors on vous dit je
vais remettre Moi quand je serai je vais
remettre de l'ordre dans les finances
publiques mais c'est d'où vient le
désordre des finances publiques
la suppordation de vote non désord dans
les finances publiques il vient du
désordre qu'on a mis dans la société
dans la dans l'économie voilà c'est
c'est et quand vous voulez quand vous
voulez remettre de l'ordre dans les
finances publiques sans remettre de
l'ordre dans la société dans l'économie
vous ne faites que mettre plus de
désordrre dans la société dans
l'économie et donc remettre désordrre
supplémentaire dans les finances
publiques vous savez c'est un peu comme
dans une entreprise c'est il y a une for
il y a une expression complètement
idiote euh qui dit quand entreise est en
difficulté je vais redresser les comptes
de l'entreprise ben non vous allez
redresser l'entreprise et si vous
redresser l'entreprise ses comptes se
redresseront sinon vous faites quoi vous
appelez le vous appelez le non vous
appelez le coskiller vous allez
redresser les comptes de l'entreprise et
puis va il va raboter tout ce qu'il peut
9 fois sur 10 si tu
l'entreprise si vous le prenez par ce
billet là c'està dire par je vais
redresser les comptes au lieu de dire je
vais redresser l'entreprise et et ça
aboutira au redressement des comptes si
vous prenez le problème à l'envers voilà
vous avez plus que c c'est ce qu'on fait
on appelle le tueur de coup là voilà va
aller voir en général d'ailleurs après
c'est encore plus on dépense encore plus
qu'avant mais ça fait ça fait 40 ans
qu'on fait ça ça fait 4 ans c'est
comprendre queon a mis enfin c'est le
désordre dans l'économie et dans la
société qui n crée cette situation des
des des des finances publiques le
constat on est 3000 milliards on l'a
fait bon c'est bien mais aprè on en sort
comment 5000 emplois de fonctionnaires
supprimés sous Sarkozy tout de même oui
bah c'était pas une bonne idée
voilà mais tout le monde était pour ça
la pression pour ça était fantastique
les les mêmes qui se plaignent
aujourd'hui de pas avoir assez de
policiers de ils étaient
pour voilà c'est c'est c'est
extraordinaire tous les gens bien
pensant là qui qui disaient il faut
faire un numérus closus pour les
médecins parce que les médecins ce sont
les prescripteurs et donc c'est eux qui
font la dépense de d'assurance de santé
voilà aujourd'hui se plaent il y a pas
de médecin mais
ils étaient tous pour ils étaient tous
pour c'était extraordinaire maintenant
il va falloir 15 ans pour arriver à à
remonter la penteoui tous ces gens qui
suivent la girouette par clientélisme
par ce que vous
voulez un jour ou l'autre ils vont payer
quand même non ils vont payer parce que
la France va tellement s il y en a qui
vont peut-être payer puis il y en a qui
payeront pas il y a toujours des gens
qui s'en tient c'est qu'ils prennent des
billets d'avion et qui cherchent àî
ailleurs qui prennent des billets
d'avion qui cherchent àil
ailleurs pas forcément il y a des gens
qui arrivent à s'entirer il a des gens
très malins voilà mais le problème le
problème n'est même n'est même pas là le
problème c'est que ça énerve toujours
les gens mais mais tout tout le monde
est coupable soit soit d'avoir décidé
soit d'avoir laissé faire
voà c'est quand les électricien gazier
faisit grève contre les il manifestait
contre les directives européennes tout
le monde disait des privilégiés rien à
faire il nous casse les pieds bon ben
voilà ben très bien comment on fait pour
nous sauver de cette chanli là mais je
sais moi je suis pas enfin moi je suis
pas là ce soir pour faire mon programme
mon mon programme politique d'abord ça
prendrait beaucoup plus de temps et et
et c'est pas le le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est c'est d'abord la prise de
conscience arrêtons c'est c'est
extraordinaire de de mais la prise de
conscience ils ont pas envie de la voir
mais elle est pas là la prise de
conscience elle est pas là je suis
désolé puisque on refait exactement la
même chose que ce qu'on fait depuis 40
ans qui nous amené là où nous en sommes
en disant de temps en temps oui c'est
pas bien ce qu'on a fait et puis on
recommence voilà c'est on recommence
regardez on dit il y a une guerre de
haute intensité en voilà maintenant la
guerre de haute intensité c'est devenu
une possibilité un risque bon non mais
bon alors on dit on va augmenter les
budgets militaires parce que pendant des
décennies et c'est à droite gauche
confondu il avait toujours chaque fois
qu'on parlait de dépenses militair il
toujours quelqu'un pour dire qui
voulez-vous qui nous menace c'est c'est
à personne donc tout ça ça ça ne pouvait
plus arriver trancher encore moins les
chars les avions les
lesconomique non mais prendant la guerre
la Guer la vraie économique ça fait mal
aussi hein oui ça fait mal mais l'autre
ça fait encore plus
malas voilà et et et et on disait mais
non il y a pas donc donc on a par tout
parlait des chars tout à l'heure tout ça
on
a on a laissé tout ça de côté on dit
maintenant on a ça y est on on a compris
on a fait on fait une loi de pramation
militaire et on on va on va faire un
effort important quelle est la variable
d'ajustement de cette loi à la fin des
fins de de de de programmation militaire
les chars les avions les canons les
bateaux et il y a pas de diplomate
là-dedans non
mais c'est on a sacrifié une fois de
plus toutes les armes de guerre de haute
intensité voilà donc d'un côté on un
discours on pense que la prise de
conscience est là et puis vous allez au
résultats et le résultat c'est que et
bien c'est toujours pareil pas de char
pas d'avion pas voilà la loi de
programmation militaire qui répond à la
guerre de au risque de guerre de ha
haute intensité tout est et personne n
remarqué ça il y a pas un si il y a des
gens qui ont remarqué il y a des gens
qui écrivent de temps en temps mais mais
mais euh bah personne n'a aosé voter
contre parce que ça aurait été on
risquit de se faire accuser de de de pas
vouloir voter des cré militaire alors
que la guerre était là enfin voyez c'est
c'est c'est c'est mais mais ça c'est
c'est enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est au
citoyen se révolter aussi hein moi je
comment le citoyen il peut se révolter
alors qu'il est mal informé com il fait
dans l'histoire voilà comme il a fait
dans l'histoire voilà pas mais si le
citoyen veut pas s'informer s'il veut
pas participer bah ben il
subit c'est tout c'est
c'est
tout ça n'est pas n'arrive pas par
hasard ça tombe pas du cè encore une
fois ça fait 40 ans que ça dure
c'est le citoyen il est alors en plus le
citoyen dans des situations de crise
c'est tous pourr tous des Salou ça c'est
normal il
souffre ça fait pas avancer ça fait pas
avancer ça fait pas avancer j fum sans
feu quand même il jamais de fumer sans
feu non c'est pas vrai d'abord il y a
des fumés sans feu parce que c'est très
facile de démolir les les et c'est et de
toute façon ça fait pas avancer les
choses si vous considérez que tout
politique est un est un pourri euh bah
il faut pas vous étonner qu'il y ait
plus de politique hein
voà bah oui hein c'est c'est et puis
ceux qui sont là c'est vous qui les avez
élu hein c'est pas en c'est vous c'est
nous hein
c'est he ils sont pas tombés du ciel
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait son pas tombé
du ciel et on vote on vote
bah on vote on milite voilà on manifeste
qu'est-ce que voulez jusqu'au jour où ça
suffira pas parce que bah à ce moment-là
ce sera la violence qui l'emportera moi
je si si mais c'est comme ça où les
société les peuples les gens réagissent
ou bien ils réagissent pas ou pas assez
mais on peut comprendre on peut
comprendre pourquoi on peut comprendre
il tout un tas de bonnes
raisons jusqu'au jour
où tout le monde de pète les plombes
puis voilà c'est c'est euh c'est ça ça
s'appelle la violence collective savez
des gens très raisonnables qui d'un seul
coup finissent par devenir très
raisonnable prenez prenez une foule qui
lche qui linche quelqu'un c'est en
général les faites de gens modérés des
bons citoyens et ce qui d'un seul coup
deviennent des bêtes féroces même pire
que des bêtes féroces ils linchent et
puis après ils redeviennent normons
voilà c'est c'est psychologie des foules
P oui ben c'est Gustave Lebon oui
Gustave Lebon entre autres oui mais
Gustave Lebon dit très bien dans sa
préface il dit bah la pendant la
révolution des gens
bourgeois tout à fait normaux sont
devenus des bêtes féroces et puis après
ils sont redevenus normaux après ils ont
service ils ont fourni les cadres de
l'Empire ils ontchin ben oui voilà mais
là encore la nature humaine donc si on
si le problème de ce pouvoir aussi c'est
ça c'est c'est l'absence de limite je
c'est comme c'est comme les lignes
rouges de la tout ça se tient c'est
comme les lignes rouges de la guerre
vous savez c'est ah bon on les franchi
il se passe rien ah bon on en franchit
encore on avance on continue un pouvoir
qui se dit j'ai pas de
limite j'ai bien le droit toute façon je
peux je peux faire la réforme des
retraites en mettant le 40article 471
l'article 40 le le le le règlement du
Sénat le puis après et le 493 par-dessus
bon c'est pas le 493 qui était en soit
le pire c'est c'est le 471 mais mais
mais personne n'avait jamais fait ça
jamais fait ça c'estàd mettre une
accrocher une réforme des retraites à
une loi de financement de la de la
sécurité sociale qui est donc voté dans
des qui qui est qui est en enfermé pour
des raisons très très très recevable
d'ailleurs qui est enfermé dans dans des
dans une durée de débat très très courte
euh personne n'avait jamais misformme
des retraites làdedans donc le résultat
on a une réforme retraite qui est même
pas votée par le par le Parlement et
vous avez 75 % des gens qui qui sont qui
qui sont qui sont contre c'est vous avez
vous avez un gouvernement qui n'est pas
capable
pas pas en mesure d'expliquer d'où
sortent les chiffres qu'il utilise mais
vous vous souvenez pas c'est c'est voilà
un député socialiste qui se lève il dit
Monsieur le Ministre d'où viennent vos
chiffres parce qu'il avait fait le tour
de tous les organismes qui pouvaient en
fir et aucun d'entre eux ne les avait
n'était les fournisseurs des chiffres
réponse du ministre je n'ai pas de
compte à vous rendre sur mes
chiffres mais il Savit pas d'où il
venait d'ailleurs on sait toujours pas
c'est un peu voà mais c'est mais c'est
euh voilà c'est c'est c'est moi j'avais
je je j'avais parlé à l'époque et et
c'est très marrant enfin c'est très
intéressant parce que dans ces
moments-là les gens ils écoutent des
choses qu'ils écoutent pas d'habitude
c'est ça ça posait la question de l'art
de gouverner c'est prévoir non non l'art
de gouverner c'est pas seulement prévoir
c'est d'abord gouverner c'est agir avant
prévoir et puis c'est pas là c'était pas
prévoir là c'était c'est le président de
la République son premier rôle c'est
l'unité de la nation ité du pays c'est
le premier rôle d'un président de la
République
et l'art de gouverner c'est c'est pour
pour un pour un président pour un
gouvernement pour d'ailleurs pour
n'importe quel décideur c'est de savoir
jusqu'où il peut aller jusqu'où il peut
aller
euh dans dans l'opposition qu'il
suscite jusqu'où il peut aller jusqu'à
quelle limite il peut aller sans mettre
en cause non pas le consensus l'adhésion
mais le
consentement parce que si une fraction
même très faible de la population ne
consent plus à accepter la règle
majoritaire de respecter la
loi ben c'est
fini fini la démocratie elle est morte
la société
bascule imaginez que vous ayez 5
millions de personnes ce qui est très
faible comme par rapport nombre de même
d'électeurs qui dit moi c'est fini je ne
consens plus je consens plus vous me
dites la loi je m'en fiche je consens
plus B c'est fini vous allez trouver les
nombre de policiers pour mettre au pas 5
millions de personnes on n'arrivait pas
à le faire avec 500000 personnes 500000
gilets jaunes au début du mouvement des
gilets jaunes si on a ré faire non au
début ils ont dit on leur disait 500000
ils étaient que
500000 c'est interdit d'aller bloquer
les rond-points il y a des 11 morts sur
les rond-points parce que personne n
prévener les automobilistes sous les
camions que que était bloqué on leur
disait vous êtes pas autorisé à aller là
ils y allaient quand même qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé après mais après la violence
a monté non après il y a eu des
mouvements de contreurrectionnels dignes
d'un pays du tier monde bah ouis tirer
dans la tête de quelqu'un pour faire un
exemple on a vu on a vu ça où on a vu ça
en
Égypte c'était pas de la technique
contre insurrectionnelle de pays du
tirmonde qu'on avait en France avec les
gilets jaunes parce que Macron il
sentait bien que quand il y avait des
gens sous l' de triom ce qui s'est passé
personne enfin que tout le monde tout le
monde le sait dans l'état et dans il y a
eu un jour le jour de la où l'art de
Triomphe a été a été
pillé la République a basculé
c'est-à-dire qu'elle était il y a eu
brusquement une une panique parce que la
la la police ne contrôlait plus rien
voilà et ils étaient moins nombreux que
les jeune du début mais contrôler il
arriv plus à maîtriser la la la la
situation voilà
que imaginez qu'il y en a un peu plus
que ça et vous voyez ce que ça peut
donner donc il faut se mettre des
limites vous pouvez pas dire j'ai bien
le droit JE M'EN FICHE de ce que vous
pensez moi voilà constitution je peux le
faire je le fais voilà B non voilà la
limite c'est vous pouvez on m'a dit mais
à ce compte là on peut plus faire de
politique impopulaire si jusqu'à un
certain point voilà et que et l'art de
gouverner c'est d'abord de se dire où
est ce où est ce point alors on peut se
tromper dans dans l'évaluation de la
limite mais au moins se poser la
question c'est toujours c'est c'est où
est-ce que je me mets la limite quels
que soient les pouvoirs que me confèrent
les
institutions quel que soit le pouvoir
que me confère le le le le le le le le
vote voilà c'est pas parce que j'ai j'ai
j'ai été élu euh que je peux faire
absolument n'importe quoi au nom de ma
major
et faire subir n'importe quoi aux autres
ça n'est pas vrai voilà parce c'est
jusqu'à quelle où est la limite du
consentement
voil mais voyez on retombe toujours sur
les mêmes choses c'est que avant de se
de de de faire des manuels de
recette pour savoir comment on va on va
réduire le poids de la dette avant ça il
y a des problèmes très profonds se c'est
que si on est dans cette situation c'est
c'est parce qu'on est en face d'une CR
crise intellectuelle et morale d'une
profondeur abysale voilà c'est que et si
vous prenez pas le problème par là vous
n'avez aucune chance d'en sortir vous
n'en sortez que encore une fois par la
violence et par le cycle habituel
infernal de la de la violence et du
retour et du du retour à un ordre un
ordre très dur voilà c'est c'est pour
combler pour combler ce faossé
intellectuel ou cette cette défaillance
il faut au moins une génération faut au
moins 10 ans ben ça dépend des moments
ça dépend Napoléon ans mais c'était
Napoléon voilà et voyez bien c'est on
parlait des médecins tout à l'heure des
numérosclosus faut 15 ans pour corriger
pour voir les premiers effets d'une
ouverture d'une lumière dans 15 ans on
sera où nous je sais pas qui restera moi
je ser pe-êre plus là mais vous avez
quel âge déjà hein vous avez quel âge 67
ans 67 ans bon ça va c'est encore un
bien vert mais dans 10 ans ça fera plus
que ça ça fera com dans 15 ans ça fera
beaucoup plus
mais vous préparez votre retraite
comment en anticipant ce genre de chos
en voyant la la
tripoté je vais je vais si vous
m'autorisez la tripote crétin qui nous
entoure comment comment vous organisez
vous dit prochaines années de vieux vous
avez une bonne bouteille planqué à la
cave en attendant attendant rien je n'y
pense pas voilà vous avez mis de la
poudre au sec comment ça se passe je
pense pas voilà votre femme
y pense un
peu non d'abord elle est plus jeune donc
et et vos enfants vous avez des enfants
ils y pense un
peu est-ce que vous discutez de ça avec
vos enfantst quel âge vos enfants je ne
discute pas de ça et voilà j'ai pas
envie d'en discuter j'ai pas envie d'y
penser mais parce que ça inéresse
pas je je vois pas pourquoi je je je
peux essayer de m'organiser une deuxème
vie professionn
voilà mais mais sinon je vois pas je je
vais pas planifier le le déclin de mon
existence don je ne sais absolument pas
vos enfants ils sont en âge de combattre
oui ils sont ils peuvent être conscrit
pas t qui n pas encore mais et vous avez
jamais discuté de ça avec eux de quoi de
ma retraite non pas de votre retraite
non mais ça y est ça ça c'est bien un
retraité ça toujours aut non vous me
dites est ce que vous pensez à votre
vous avez pensé à leur parler de la
guerre qui se profile devant nous
euh en parlerit oui enfin comme comme
comme n'importe qui on par est-ce que
vous avez un plan du genre si Macron
nous fait un petit un petit caca nerveux
à
20h pas fin les passeports sont là vous
vous barrez parce qu'il va nous envoyer
va nous envoyer au j'ai pas de plan et
je si a la guerre je vais pas organiser
le s'ils veulent partir ils partiront
mais je vais pas organiser le le départ
de mes de mes enfants enfin je est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous c'est le
problème c'est que la guerre quand elle
est là elle concerne tout le monde al
peut t imaginez-vous vous avez 25 ans
imaginez-vous vos 25 ans d'accord vous
avez 25 ans maintenant là ça remonte à
loin vous vous voyez partir à la guerre
derrière
Macron mais je encore une fois quoi je
je
je mais si c'est c'est imaginez que on
nous entraîne dans cette dans une guerre
de ce genre vous allez faire quoi
déserter non il y a des choses plus
intéressantes à faire avant quz quoi
vous allez prendre des bombes et vous
allez rien dire vous quelle que soit la
cause de la guerre quel que soit le
voilà sauf si on a on est en face d'un
pouvoir totalitaire c'est c'est c'est
c'est autre chose mais euh benah je sais
pas quand la guerre est là on défend son
pays quoi
je est-ce qu'on défend le pays là ou
est-ce qu'on défend des intérêts
financiers
c'est même pas des intérêts financiers
ne serait trop simple c'est quoi alors
Ken avait une très belle formule qui
peut-être pas de lui d'ailleurs mais
mais qui qui qu' utilisait souvent il
disait le le le monde n'est pas tant
gouverné par des intérêts que par des
idées voilà et ça on néglige toujours
alors on cherche qui va gagner quoi qui
c'est c'est pas les grandes puissances
financiires qui gouvernent le monde il
gouvern même pas la finance la finance
elle se gouverne toute seule dans C
espèce de marmite invraisemblable qui
s'appelle les marchés
financiers que personne ne gouverne qui
son truc qui mène quand il fonctionnent
bien il March au hasard donc
voà et on accroche le sort du monde au
hasard des marchés financiers c'est
fantastique c'est quand même c'est quand
même dramatique marchés financiers c'éit
pour financer les entreprises non c'est
ça non mais c'est plus le cas non là
c'est des parasites alors il y a
toujours une part de pour assurer la
liquidité toujours une part de spécul
mais là c'est ce qu'on a fabriqué est un
système est un système délirant mais je
vais vous dire qu moi j'ai j'ai
appartenu à une à une famille politique
qui n'était plus une famille non mais
c'est vrai ENF qui était plus une
famille politique c'est une famille qui
est enraciné dans un courant de
pensée dans un imaginaire dans
un là c'était un céit quand même devenu
beaucoup un cartel électoral comme tous
les autres partis aujourd'hui c'est des
drames de la de la politique actuelle
c'est qu'elle est plus enracinée dans
dans des courants dans des courants de
pensée cartel électoral joue le vol h
bah oui c'est ça c'est c'est pour
pourquoi pourquoi le Parti socialiste
pourquoi les partis qu'on appelle le
gouvernement ils onts sont dans cet état
parce que parce qu'ils ont cessé d'être
des ils ont cessé d'être en rassignés
dans des familles politiques c'estàd on
a mis ensemble des gens qui pensaient
pas la même chose du tout euh c'est
c'est les les les courants politiques
c'est c'est c'est très ancien ce sont
des
alors ils ont ils s'expriment de façon
différente en fonction des époques mais
mais ce sont des courants très anciens
et très profond Maler disait quand il
parlait du golisme il disait le golisme
c'est la force du nom dans l'histoire
nonom no et il disait le nom du 18 juin
fait écho à celui de jeanc et à celui
d'antigon alors on peut rire en disant
c'est du malero c'est mais en fait c'est
assez c'est assez profond c'est dire que
même le le le golisme N pas n'a pas
commencé le 18 juin même le
golobonapartisme n'a pas commencé avec
avec Napoléon
euh et dans dans dans cette dans dans
cette dans cette phrase
euh il y a il y a il y a l'idée
que la France est une idée très ancienne
et le rapport à la
nation même si on nppelait pas ça encore
la nation à l'époque mais c'est quand il
parle de Jean d'c c'est c'est ça ça ça
veut dire quelque chose c'est et quand
il parle d'Antigone c'est encore mieux
c'est c'est oui ça ça dépasse même notre
notre propre histoire parce que ça veut
dire
que une vraie famille politique un vrai
courant politique c'est aussi une idée
de l'homme très
ancienne voilà c'est une idée de la
dignité ou de la liberté de de de de
l'homme alors c'est pas parce qu'on a
fait n'importe quoi
d'Antigone depuis que il
fautut faut éluder cette ciidé
que la politique n'a de sens ancré dans
des choses aussi profondes et moi quand
j'étais dans dans ce qui n'était plus
vraimentour une famille politique quand
on disait bon on a quand même un
problème avec la finance globale alors
c'est pas ça ça revient pas à dire la
finance est mon ennemi tout ça pour
après lui faire tous les cadeaux de la
terre mais mais dire que il y a un
problème avec la finance globale oui il
y a un problème avec la finance globale
voilà c'est et il y a toujours un pour
dire on n'est pas chez les communistes
ici parce que sont devenus les familles
politiques c'està-dire on est passé de
de Goul la politique de la France pas la
corbeille ah on n'est pas chez les
communistes ici c'est magnifique hein
c'est magnifique ah oui c'est c'est un
raccourci historique c'est formidable je
dirais même
et moi je suis pas du tout formidable de
terrifiant moi je suis je suis pas
antiapitaliste je suis pas je je pense
que c'est pas vrai vous êtes arrivé ici
avec ave l'humanité sous le bras non
c'est pas vrai ça un mensonge de
politicien ça mais c'est pas ça je suis
je suis pas anticapitaliste mais c'est
typique le capitaliste je pense c'est
une force de création extraordinaire
sauf que toutes les forces de création
sont aussi des forces de
destruction c'est
c'est
la
la l'innovation destructrice c'est c'est
c'est c'est une jolie formule mais c'est
pas qu'une formule et en fait c'est la
destruction créatrice j'ai pas compris
vous avez dit quoi on dit parle souvent
de la destruction créatrice
euh
parinnovation he c'est Ricardo non c'est
non c'est pas Ricardo je fais exprès pas
grave pas Ricardo mais mais c'est c'est
voilà c'est une force de toute force de
création est aussi une force de
destruction il faut la canalyser parce
que c'est c'est ça peut être d'une
violence inoui le capitalisme soit vous
le canalisez vous avez l'exemple des TR
glorieuse vous en tirez le le meilleur
parti euh soit vous le laissez libre on
appelle ça le capitalisme sauvage mais
et vous laissez libre cours à la
terrible violence de de l'instinct de
possession de domination de deinstinct
de d'inin de lucre le voilà et et ça
devient simplement une puissance de
destruction
voilà et ça ça me fait pas de
moi ni un communiste ni un
anticapitaliste
ni juste comprendre que si vous laiss
vous le laissez totalement libre bah il
va dévorer tout sur son passage
voilà c'est encore c'est la nature
c'estàdire ça devient c'est ça devient
une espèce de darwinisme social de de
c'est la sélection naturelle c'est ben
très bien mais ça ça c'est ça c'est la
la face violente de la nature
c'est mais mais quand quand on perd tout
ça de vue quand quand et quand on a on a
plus enfin les familles politique
n'existe plus c'est-à-dire des familles
de pensée qui ont qui ont un rapport
parinttellectuel philosophique morale
particulier à la violence à la nature de
l'homme à sa liberté à à sa dignité
à son à son pays à sa civilisation il y
a plus de politique voilà c'est c'est il
n'y a plus que on pense on ne pense plus
qu'à ce qui est nécessaire pour sa
réélection voilà et alors quand le pire
quand on n pas de limite c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ça c'est on a on a
fait de deux grandes de deux grandes
bêtises le quinena et le quinena non
renouvelable enfin pas renouvelable
au-delà de deux fois
bon ah on peut se dire c'est bien que ça
limite le temps le résultat c'est que
dans le deè le 2è
quinquena premièrement la majorité elle
sait qu'il y a pas il a le le pouvoir en
place n'a pas de suite donc elle
commence à lâcher avant bien avant la
fin le début et deuxièmement celui celui
qui est au pouvoir il sait qu'il a pas
besoin de de il a pas besoin de
satisfaire les gens il a plus de limite
hein c'est c'est il s'en fout puisque de
toute façon il sera pas réélu donc ça a
pas de limite et là voilà c'est c'est
donc c'est c'est tout ça est absurde là
encore on fait des réformes sans tenir
compte de ce qui'est la nature humaine
bah on y est là c'est très bien je voilà
je peux j'ai le droit je m'en fous
puisque de toute façon je je vais même
pas vous redemander de voter pour pour
moi donc ouais non mais il faut quand
même faire CFF parce que c'est quand
même la France et les Français hein
c'est pas
oui bien sûr il faut faire ga je suis
d'accord mais
mais on a fait tout ça on a fait tout ça
avec la sentiment de de tout le monde
c'est c'est quand on a fait le quineda
il un T de gens sont pas allés voter ils
savaient même pas ce que ça ça pouvait
vouloirés ça pouvit représenter toute la
classe politique était d'accord pour
pour pour le faire parce qu'elle pensait
que c'était poulaire bon B voilà on a le
quinquena voilà et puis après on a dit
ah si on limite à deux ça aussi ça va
être populaire bon ben on a limité à
deux puis voilà on est maintenant on est
confronté à on est confronté à ça à
Macron bah ce qui se passe oui ça fait
3h23 que nous sommes en direct c'est
trop long avant je parle deoup non mais
c'est trop long parce que voilà on a on
a brassé peutêtre TR de CH en fait on
est non pas du tout on est plus de 5000
en direct que sur YouTube tu m'affiches
les chiffres de Twitter merci et est-ce
qu'il y a un truc qu'on n pas abordé ou
un sujet que vous a oui y en a il y en
il y en a énormément mais mais c'est ça
sert à rien de vouloir tout tout aborder
en même en 3h 25 minutes c'est c'est
après on devient superficiel ça ça ne
sert plus à rien mais je je parle de
quoi votre dernier bouquin il parle de
tout ça voilà c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on
fait s'appelle ça s'appelle la 7e fois
les murailles tomb
c'est au quelles éditions c'est aux
éditions du Rocher ça coûte combien euh
je sais plus 20 et quelques prenez
combien j'en sais
rien mais j'en sais rien voilà aussi à
peu près toujours les mêmes les les
mêmes contrats voilà j'en sais rien pas
grand-chose mais par
par par livre c'est un livre épai donc
il a des images non il y a pas d'images
mince alors ou pasvoyer je sais mais
voilà c'est donc un moment j'ai eu envie
de de de j'ai envie de de de de tout
mettre et de montrer comment les choses
se tenaient ensemble VO en fonction de
ce que ce que je pouvais penser de ce
que j'avais ce que j'avais vécu pendant
40 ans soit au milieu du dans les
cercles du pouvoir soit autour soit en
dehors soit en dedans
euh voilà donc il y a il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vont de la ça va
de la de la culture à la finance en
passant par la par la guerre par par le
droit par
le et le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
tout ce qui a cheminé souterrainement
pendant des
décennies est en train de se coaguler en
une crise qui est qui est crise
multiforme don qui deviennent de plus en
plus difficile à à à maîtriser c'est
quelle que soit la direction vers
laquelle vous tournez vos
regard vous tombez sur un dérèglement
majeur c'est c'est voilà vous regardez
le droit drit alors je parle même pas de
droit international parce que c'est on
en a déjà parlé vous avez lu l'art de la
guerre oui j'ai lu l'art de la guerre
ouis des neuf terrains vous ont gardz
quoi quand vous dites cette phrase là
partout je pose mon regard et la suite
c'est tout est pourri autour et oui
enfin pas pourri dérèglé oui non mais
d'accord c'est non mais c'est un
dérèglement total en face de nous il y a
une tempettete de merde qui est en train
de se se profiler et on a Riri Fifi et
Loulou qui joue à la guerre oui oui avec
avec moustachu copie de service de
renseignement poutré de Z on a
journaliste qui est le petit
télégraphiste ou qui fait du
clientélisme qui fait du ménage et il y
a le français qui joue dans les règles
du jeu qui paye ses impôts qui essaie
d'éduquer ses gamins qui se retrouve au
milieu de Riri Fifi loulou joue à être
président de la République non mais on
fait quoi là
on fait quoi oui mais on fait français
encore une encore une FO est-ce qu'on
réveille nos vieux démons encore une
fois pendant 40 ans mais c'est toujours
comme ça pendant 40 ans non pas pendant
40s tout le monde très intéressant c'est
que c'est que tout le monde ne s'est
occupé que de ces problèmes ce que je
comprends pas tous mais si enfin la
plupart c'est comme ça c'est c'est des
militaires qui ont essayé de maintenir
ce qu'il y avait à maintenir il y a des
profs qui essayé de maintenir ce qu' ons
il y a des profs qui pu il a des profs
qui qui qui pas bah oui ENF voilà et
puis comme on payit pas les profs on a
on a eu des n plus pu recruter au même
niveau de de sélectivité bon et puis non
seulement ils étaient mal payés mais
leurs conditions de travail se sont
totalement dégradé mais souvenez-vous ce
qu'on disait des profs oui alors ils ont
trop de vacances alors ils sont ils sont
payés à r fout enfin c'est
extraordinaire quoi les les profs au
début des années 80 prof débutant ça
gagné
2,2 SMIC ou ou trois SMIC euh voilà il y
a il y a y a il y a 2 ans un prof
débutant ça gagnit 1,1 SMIG vous voyez
la la la l'effondrement
euheffondrement social du du du du du du
du professeur quoi je veux dire de
l'enseignant et en plus on lui crache à
la figure les les parents dans l'école
pour lui pour pour lui casser la figure
euh les les élèfes font pareil euh et
quand il lui arrive quand il est menacé
on dit pas de vague hein pendant des
années on a expliqué que il se passait
rien c'est non non pas de violence à
l'école c'est jusqu'au jour oùù le
mouvement pas de vague à la suite d'un
incident c'est c'est révélé et mais ça
n'a rien changé voilà c'est que
l'histoire de Samuel paaty c'est quoi
c'est une histoire de pas de vague
c'est-à-dire le au fond le coupable
jusqu'à ce qu'on lui coupe la tête le
coupable du désordre bah c'était
pati voilà c'est c'est c'est
extraordinaire quoi c'est
euh VO ce qui se passe dans l'école
c'est enfin le rapport Robain il date du
début des années 2000 il y a tout dedans
inspecteur c'est une mission de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale C il y a tout on l'a mis dans
un tiroir tous les 5 ans ou 10 ans dire
ah non mais nous on nenterre pas de plus
jamais on enterrera ce genre de chos et
c'est c'est toujours la même histoire
c'est bon euh question internet oui euh
pour HRY guenou seriez-vous d'accord
d'organiser un débat sur surw avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous voulez discuter
avec Jean-Luc oui moi d'abord oui je moi
je le connais bien et d'autre part euh
j'ai souvent débattu avec luiil euh mais
moi aujourd'hui je je ne veux pas faire
de débat avec des euh personnalités
politiques en fonction enfin qui sont en
euh si il est chef d' chef il est en
réalité le chef d'un parti même si voilà
donc qui vous voulez pour discuter hein
vous voulez qui pour discuter bah des
gens qui sont pas des gens soit qui sont
qui ont fait de la politique mais qui
n'en font plus soit des intellectuels
soit
des des experts des spécialistes de
sujet ou ou des ou des journalistes tout
ce que vous voudrez mais je veux pas
rentrer dans le je veux pas rentrer hein
Bernard Levi
je peux discuter avec Bernard Levi mais
ça ça sera pas je suis pas sûr que ça
soit un débat B très fécond ni pour lui
ni pour moi
quoi voilà je suis pas
sûr
que on va avoir un
échange qui va apporter quelque chose à
à aux gens qui vont le qui vont le
regarder voilà je encore une fois c'est
vous parle de mélanchot moi je c'est je
refuse pas de débattre avec avec
Jean-Luc mélanchot en tant que tel c'est
pas c'est c'est une fois je l'ai fait
plus plusieurs fois mais je faisais de
la politique lui aussi
euh je ne veux pas aujourd'hui rentrer
dans le débat politique voilà c'est
c'est je veux bien parler de la
politique mais je je veux pas rentrer
dans le débat des des politicien sans
qu'il soit péjoratif dans ma dans ma
bouche hein c'est euh non mais on a pas
de temps à perdre quoi hein on n pas de
temps à perdre mais c'est pas que pas de
temps à perdre c'est que c'est que ils
ont des enjeux oui la place à la
contintine
on pas des G qui ont des enjeux très
différents j'ai appris ça moi dans ma
longue vie en ça ça ça sert à rien ça n
voilà je deviens si je fais ça si je
suis quand on sera d'accord je on dira
que Jef je je suis l'allié de de LFI ce
qui est pas mon cas parce que autant je
trouve qu'il est intelligent mais mais
il a quand même il a il a parfois dérapé
par rapport à ce qu'il était auparavant
autant il y a dans lesfi des gens que je
je je avec qui je j'ai pas vraiment j'ai
pas envie de discuter pas seulement
parce qu'ils font de la politique hein
c'est et boire une bière si non boire
une bière discuter autour d'invers c'est
possible non mais il y a des
gens on arrive à la fin quand même de
notre interview euh est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour trois bouquins
incseillés ah je vais vous répondre
peut-être la même chose que j'ai dû vous
répondre là la la la pierre et le LOU
pierre et l loup Riri Fifi loulou à
l'Élysée Tintin Tintin fait la guerre
non c'était ça non
euh alors pour pour pour s'ouvrir pour
s'ouvrir l'esprit euh j'ai cru que vous
alliez dire pour s'ouvrir les veines non
il y a des choses alors ça dépend à qui
on on les fait lire si
euh si j'avais à faire
lire un un livre des gens qui veulent
faire de la politique ou qui veulent
réfléchir à la politique bon des gens
des gens stupides quoi voilà euh je
dirais d'abord l'homme révolté de Camu
ou l'homme révolté c'est un homme c'est
c'est c'est un homme qui dit non qui
a-t-il dans ce nom il y a vous avez
franchi une limite c'est c'est c'est je
pense qu'il aurait beaucoup attiré pour
la la vous voulez qu'on fasse envoyer à
l'Élysée vous voulez qu'on fasse envoyer
à l'Élysée non mais je veux pas rentrer
dans vous essayez de m'entraîner sur des
terrains j'ai c'est le président de la
République a envie de consulter des gens
il le fait puis voilà moi jamais
consulté d'ailleurs je ne le réclame
pas non c'est c'est le fait qu'il
convoque François Hollande et Nicolas
Sarkozi juste après avoir fait Guer qui
consulte ses s PRD mais c'est un message
c'est un message c'est consulter ses
aïux montrer qu'on a l'approbation de
ses
pères à Poutine que on est tous unis
derrière lui c'est du [__] de théâtre
oui bien sûr mais c'est th c'est du
Sunzu acheté sur
wish non mais sans déconner ils ont pas
vu venir ils ont pas vu ils ont pas vu
la la guerre venir il y avait personne
sur le terrain les Russes monraent les
missilees hypersonicque c'était en 2018
ou en 2017 on s'est pas réarmé notre
projection diplomatique c'est Riri Fifi
loulou vont travailler dans des boîtes
de cybersécurité c'est mais c'est une
non mais on a envie de se se lever et
ils vont faire les kékés sur les
plateaux télé mais on a envie de se
lever de faire continue pas à faire ton
malin tu vas prendre très cher là il
faut il faut arrêter de prendre les
français pour des couillons là
maintenant ben je suis bien d'accord
mais il faut aussi que les français
arrêtent de se laisser prendre pour des
couillons voilà est-ce que c'est votre
conseil pour les jeunes générations quoi
mon conseil pour les jeunes générations
c'est que c'est oui manque de bouquin on
va on va y venir j'ai bon j'ai pas de
conseils à donner au au jeunes
générations sauf juste un un petit
rappel c'est vous n'êtes pas meilleur
que ceux qui vous ont précédé voilà
c'est-à-dire vous il y a mais oui il y a
c'est c'est il y a plus aucune humilité
dans ce dans dans ce monde c'est encore
une fois l'histoire c'est c'est pas une
un ornement de l'esprit c'est
c'est apprendre à travers ce qui s'est
passé aussi ce que nous sommes et si
nous oublions ce que nous sommes nous
pvons avir toute l'intelligence
artificiel du monde euh non mais euh t
tous les T t tous
les tous les algorithmes toutes les des
données de masse qu'on veut euh c'est on
va mal finir quand même voilà c'est
c'est bah il y a un moment c'est c'est
c'est aussi au moins aussi important euh
que tous nos progrès techniques
technologiqu et même scientifique VO
c'est bon
euh ça ça ça vaut pour tout le monde Je
non le monde ne commence pas avec vous
pas plus qu'avec moi non qu à la
naissance nous ne sommes pas un
commencement nous sommes une
continuation voilà nous sommes habités
par par par des choses que nous ne
voyons pas et qui nous
déterminent et qui viennent de très très
loin c'est
c'est voilà tout tout le monde n'est pas
obligé de passer son temps à faire de
l'anthropologie mais les les voyez les
les les les structures inconscientes du
langage
B elles sont bien là on en est conscient
et elles ont pas commencé avec
nous voilà c'est
c'est donc ça commence pas enfin c'est
cette idée folle tout commence avec moi
ben non tout commences pas avec toi même
toi tu commences pas avec
toi vous avez fait une psychothérapie
dans votre vie non vous avez fait votre
test
colorectal cancer colorectal pas
récemment bon il va falloir faire
attention à ça ouais il me faut de
bouquins alors de de deux bouquins donc
l'homme révolté mais ça c'est bien aussi
pour les jeunes générations euh mais qui
pourrait lire aussi euh le premier homme
ça serait toujours de Camu ça serait ça
serait pas mal aussi voilà enfin moi
c'est le B le livre le plus émouvant que
j'ai lu de ma vie mais ça tenait
peut-être aussi au fait qu'une partie de
ma vie ressemblait assez à l' à
l'enfance de Camu voilà élevé par sa
mère et sa grand-mère euh euh sa mère
était femme de ménage cétait
c'est donc ça m'a particulièrement
intéressé particulièrement touché c'est
c'est il y a la plus belle phrase que
j'ai lu dans un dans un livre dans ce
dans dans le premier homme euh c'est
c'est ce dernier livre que que Camu qui
est un livre autobiographique était en
train d'écrire euh lorsqu'il a eu un
accident de VO est mort dans un accident
de voiture
euh voilà donc mais il est était presque
achevé pas pas tout à fait
c'est c'est vraiment un magnifique et et
Camu
raconte une histoire que j'ai trouvé
très
bouleversante au début de l'année de
l'année scolaire à l'école avant on
remplissait des petites fiches nonom
prénom du père de la mère professionère
de la
mère alors moi j'avais un peu de mal
avec la case P parce que parce que je
n'avais pas de pre bon
euh lui il avait pas de mal sur ce ce
son père était mort à la guerre mais là
c'était le cas du de la moitié de la
classe Première Guerre mondiale donc
mais après il y a les profession
profession de la
mer alors il raconte
que femme de ménage pas terrible quand
même donc il cherche ce qu' pourrait
mettre à la place il finit par mettre
domestique ça lui paraissait mieux et il
dit qu'après avoir écrit
ça pour la première fois de sa vie il a
eu honte d'avoir eu
honte
VO bon pardon ça inéresse personne sauf
sauf moi mais mais euh c'est
euh c'est un un livre qui contient une
phrase comme celle-ci une expérience de
la vie de de ce genre et celui qui écrit
ce ce ce ce livre mérite une très grande
attention euh pour ce qui est de la
formation de de l'esprit et de la
conscience voilà je ferme cette
parenthèse
euh
après il y a un autre livre que
je je dis ça parce que je viens de de le
relire qui est les les grands cimetières
sous la lune de
Bernanos très très très instructif alors
c'est un
personnage qu'on connaît moins
aujourd'hui parce que il y a plus de
Gard des Michard le journal l'encuré de
campagne de Satan tout ça c'est plus
dans n'en parle plus dans les classes de
littérature mais
euh puis c'est un personnage c'est un
personnage de droite câau
euh qui a été au moins aussi antisémite
que les
autres
euh mais qui n'est pas que ça pas que ça
qui
et qui
a qui a un personnage qui quand même
très intéressant parce que ce personnage
de droite nationale ou nationaliste quez
va va dénoncer le le régime franquiste
va refuser d' laabichi partir en préfère
partir en exil que de que de collaborer
euh il a
euh il a c'est c'est c'est une une
férocité enfin une férocité par rapport
à ce qu'il appelle le le parti de
l'ordre la droite nationale le le et il
dit des choses étonnantes il dit par
exemple en parlant du parti de l'ordre
en s'adressant à à eux il dit mais votre
ordre
l'ordre c'est depuis un siècle c'est
l'ordre
libéral
1937 l'ordre libéral et puis fait la
liste des des turpitudes sociales de cet
ordre libéral enfin des des des des
enfants qui travail des des des gens qui
arrivent pas à finir les fins de mois et
cetera c'est c'est c'est intéressant on
s'y croirit quoi voouà c'est et à un
moment donné il
décrit un épisode qui est qui est
extraordire je trouve extraordinaire moi
mais il achète il vivait il vivait il a
vécu un certain temps à Palma de maork
puis il rentre à Paris c'est là qu'il a
vu d'ailleurs les les les répressions
franquistes les fusillerschin
euh et il rentre à à Paris il achète un
un jour il achète un journal
euh journal national donc droite
nationale les marchands de journaux il y
avait un marchand de journaux par
journaux à l'époque hein c'est c'est euh
Chun avec son tas de journaux et on
descend et le le le marchand de journaux
bavarde avec lui bon vient vient barder
avec lui et et marchand journau il est
aussi à droite que son journal bon
droite de encore une fois de de l'époque
C et et pour ce que il regarde il voit
passer devant eux une
manifestation et on est en début de
l'année 1937 le le c'est le moment
d'ailles où le Front populaire enfin
Blom va va chuter parce qu'il arrive pas
à faire passer sa sa sa il arrive pas à
faire passer la retraite des vieux
bon et il voit il décrit ça il dit c'est
espèce de horde de de de de gens
misérables et denté
mal habillé enfin c'est c'est décrit ça
de façon assez assez assez horrible et
qui réclam le retraite qui réclam une
retraite il son et le marchand le
marchand de jourau de droite qui est
avec lui là il regarde ce spectacle et
puis il crie
Salau à l'endr à l'endroit des des à
l'endroit des retraités misérables qui
qui étalent leur misère sur la sur la
phique et il a cette réflexion en
entendant ça il dit oh mon
pays
oh mon pays voilà bah de temps en temps
j'ai envie de dire oh mon
pays un autre Mo à
rajouter non il y a tellement de livres
que j'aimerais que les gens j'aimerais
que les gens lisent
mais en ça c'est un c'est un témoignage
et puis euh oh puis ils ont qu'à lire
les mémoires d'outretombe ça leur fera
du bien voilà c'est moi je l'ai lu
quatre fois
donc j'aime pas la façon dont dont
château brillant parle de Napoléon
encore que il a au moins il a compris
que c'était quand même que c'était quand
même un grand personnage de l'histoire
mais mais c'est c'est c'est quand même
un des plus beaux morceaux de la
littérature
française
au moins pour ça ça justement il
explique quelque part il explique en
fait pour connaître le monde lui qui a
pas mal voyagé qu même Mme beaucoup pour
connaître le monde il y a pas besoin
d'aller courir le monde et que avec en
lisant et en réfléchissant on peut
connaître encore mieux le monde que que
faisant tout le tour il y a un passage
comme ça très intéressant euh un peu
comme julverne quoi un peu comme Jul
Verne oui mais voilà et mais j c'est de
la fiction
lui il l' avait fait de de Paris à
Jérusalem il a été ambassadeur à Londres
il était allé aux États-Unis en Amérique
enfin je voilà je veux dire en Italie
bon et
euh il dit ça et c'est c'est c'est c'est
magnifique dans ce monde où on croit que
c'est en c'est c'est c'est c'est en
s'enfuyant à l'autre bout du monde qu'on
va devenir à la fois meilleur plus
intelligent ce qui veut pas dire qu'il
faut faut pas voyager qu'il faut pas
aller voir le monde mais c'est c'est
c'est devenu c'est sans s'enfuyant au
bout du monde qu'on se rend compte que
la France il faut la défendre
oui Henry Guen on arrive à la fin de
notre émission
déjà
3h45 personne va aller jusqu'au bout de
bah il y a plus de 5800 personnes là oui
ben là ils écoutent plus ils dorment
oublié
d'éteindre vous avez pris le record de
la chaîne qui était détenu par Monsieur
Devillier h juste derrière il y avait
l'ambassadeur de Chine et et
euh merci ce ce fut un vrai plaisir
Henry Guenot merci ben merci à
[Musique]
vous